Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW, unsere kleine Welt. Mein Name ist Tim
Pritlove und ich begrüße alle zur 122.
Ausgabe von UKW. Und da sich andere Krisen noch nicht so recht aufdrängen wollen,
bleiben wir bei der Ukraine und das heißt, ich begrüße Pavel auf der anderen Seite des Apparats.
Hallo Tim.
Genau. Wir wollen mal wieder zusammenfassen, was passiert ist und wir haben
jetzt wieder fast zwei Monate verstreichen lassen.
Letzte Sendung ist am 4. Mai 2024 veröffentlicht worden.
Wir haben jetzt zum Zeitpunkt der Aufnahme den 23.
Juni. Die sind also nicht ganz zwei Monate, aber es ist auf jeden Fall wieder
eine ganze Menge passiert.
Und ja, ist immer so eine Abwägungssache, weil man sich jetzt eigentlich wirklich wieder hinsetzt.
Man beobachtet immer alles, denkt sich so, irgendwie passiert gar nicht so richtig
was. Und dann passiert auf einmal ganz viel.
Und dann denkt man sich, oh, keine Zeit jetzt Sendung aufzunehmen.
Und bis es dann mal wieder passt, ist schon wieder so viel passiert.
Naja, aber wir bleiben bei unserem Konzept und fassen jetzt erstmal ein wenig
die militärische Situation zusammen und was sich quasi so on the battleground auch so tut,
um dann vor allem nochmal so ein paar politische Beobachtungen zu machen.
Gerade politisch, glaube ich, ist jetzt gerade sehr viel passiert.
Also ich würde mal sagen, durch die Entscheidung der USA jetzt auch Angriffe
auf russisches Gebiet zu ermöglichen, sind wir jetzt wieder an so einem,
ich will es nicht einen Wendepunkt nennen, aber das ist zumindest so ein weiterer
Meilenstein, glaube ich, in diesem Konflikt, von dem wir leider wahrscheinlich
noch ein paar haben werden,
aber da reden wir dann nachher drüber.
Bleiben wir erstmal beim Militärischen. Oder, Pavel?
Ja, so machen wir das. Alles klar.
Ja, was ist passiert? Also...
Zur Erinnerung, als wir in der letzten Sendung das Thema besprochen haben,
da war ja gerade dieser Beschluss durch, dass jetzt eben doch 60 Milliarden
US-Dollar freigegeben werden,
also der ewige Kampf im Kongress der Republikaner gegen die Demokraten ist dann
so umgeschlagen, dass dann eben doch beschlossen wurde, wieder diese Zahlungen
und damit eben auch die Waffenlieferungen an die Ukraine aufzunehmen.
Während die Europäer in der Zwischenzeit natürlich alles versucht haben,
was ihnen sozusagen möglich ist, das aufzufangen, muss man halt einfach feststellen,
Europa ist halt nicht so viel möglich.
Und die Unterstützung der USA ist schon kriegsentscheidend, das kann man schon sagen.
Wäre das jetzt noch weitere ein, zwei Monate herausgezögert worden,
dann würden wir jetzt sicherlich sehr viel pessimistischer auf die Situation
blicken, als wir es jetzt tun.
Denn diese Waffenlieferungen sind dann auch relativ schnell aufgenommen worden. Das dauert natürlich.
Viel von dem Material wird vermutlich schon in Deutschland und in Polen mehr
oder weniger aufgehäuft gewesen sein und mehr oder weniger abreisebereit.
Aber trotzdem, es muss ja in die Ukraine kommen, es muss dort verteilt werden,
es muss an die richtigen Stellen kommen, man muss dann eben auch schauen,
wie ist denn jetzt die aktuelle militärische Situation,
wer braucht denn was am dringendsten, wie müssen wir das jetzt priorisieren.
Und man hat also gesehen, wie das dann so über ein paar Wochen sich langsam
eingepegelt hat, aber man kann festhalten,
das hat dazu geführt, dass die Vorstöße der Russen und wir hatten ja vor allem
diesen etwas größeren Vorstoß bei Avdivka,
dass die dann alle so mehr oder weniger sofort zum Halten gekommen sind.
Das hat viel damit zu tun, dass die Artillerie Munition verfügbar war und vor
allem, dass auch die Ukraine ihre Bestände, die sie hatten, nicht mehr so arg rationieren mussten.
Aber es betrifft auch andere Waffensysteme, wie zum Beispiel Heimas.
Also da ist eine Menge passiert und das hat eben dann dazu geführt,
dass die Situation dann erstmal im besseren Sinne sich wieder eingefroren hat.
Ja, wenn du es schon gerade erwähnt hast, also mittlerweile scheinen
die ersten Lieferungen auch aus dem tschechischen Artilleriedeal dann in der
Ukraine einzutreffen und das sind bis zu 100.000 Granaten im Monat und es wurde
wohl auch auf einen Schlag eine sehr hohe Zahl an Einmaßraketen geliefert,
also Gimlas.
Und so in der Größenordnung wohl bis zu 1.000 Stück.
Also sozusagen größenordnungsmäßig ist jetzt in kurzer Zeit so viel eingetroffen
wie im gesamten Kriegsverlauf bisher an Heimars-Munition.
Und mit den Granaten ist halt jetzt die russische Artillerieüberlegenheit,
was so die Anzahl von Feuer angeht, von vorher 8 bis 10 zu 1 auf 4 bis 5 zu 1 gesunken ungefähr.
Das heißt, die Russen haben nach wie vor eine hohe Überlegenheit,
was jetzt die Zahl an Artilleriegeschossen angeht, aber sie treffen halt nicht
so gut, weswegen das nicht so ganz so dramatisch ist, wie jetzt eine Zahl von 4 bis 5 zu 1 klingt.
Aber ich kann sagen, dass nach wie vor Russland einfach materiell überlegen
ist, so trotz der westlichen Lieferungen.
Aber das reicht halt nicht, diese materielle Überlegenheit, ich meine die hatte
Russland immer schon, aber in der Verteidigung konnte dann einfach die Ukraine auch dagegen halten.
Das hat natürlich auch damit zu tun, dass sie in der Regel auch die präziseren
Artilleriesysteme haben, das heißt die können ihre Munition auch effektiver
einsetzen als die Russen, die dann teilweise doch sehr viel ungenaueres Gerät am Start haben.
Das Ergebnis ist, dass jetzt eigentlich alle Frontverläufe im Süden und im Osten
so weitgehend stabil sind.
Hervorzuheben ist sicherlich die Situation um Chassiv-Yar. Das ist so der nächstgelegene
östliche wichtige strategische Ort von Bachmut.
Wir erinnern uns, wo es da im letzten Jahr diesen Dauerkrieg gab um diese Stadt,
die ja an sich strategisch erstmal nicht so wichtig war, sondern die Russen
einfach im Wesentlichen vor allem viel Personal verloren haben.
Und trotzdem diese Stadt dann eingenommen haben.
Chassivja wiederum wäre jetzt allerdings sehr fatal,
wenn die Ukraine die verlieren würde, diese Stadt, weil das schon ein wenig
dann das Tor öffnet zu dem entscheidenden Riegel dieser mehrere Städte,
die in so einer Kette angeordnet sind.
Sind Slowjansk, Kramatorsk, Drushkivka und Konstantinivka.
Das sind halt dann auch wiederum gut besiedelte Städte und gerade Kramatorsk
ist halt auch ein dauerhafter Stronghold der Ukraine gewesen.
Also schon über den ganzen Konflikt über zehn Jahre ist das eine der wichtigsten Militärbasen.
Das ist jetzt auch nichts, was jetzt für die Russen einfach zu nehmen wäre,
wenn jetzt Chassiv-Yar fällt,
aber nichtsdestotrotz ist es natürlich wichtig, hier die Russen keinen Meter
vorankommen zu lassen und da entwickeln sich gerade die heftigsten Kämpfe,
kann man sagen, im Osten.
Im Süden gibt es nur so einzelne Vorstöße.
Insgesamt behauptet Putin jetzt so 700.000 Soldaten im Kampf zu haben, ob diese Zahl stimmt.
Weiß ich nicht, aber ich denke mal allgemein liegen die Schätzungen etwas niedriger,
aber trotzdem haben die Russen mit Sicherheit derzeit mehr Personal am Start,
als sie das bei ihrer ursprünglichen Offensive hatten.
Sie sind ja mit 300.000 herangegangen, gehen wir mal davon aus,
dass es so eine halbe Million ist und andererseits nähern sie sich auch beständig
der halben Million an Verlusten in diesem Krieg.
Genau, das ist das Interessante an dieser Zahl,
wenn man die jetzt ernst nimmt und zusammenrechnet, wie viele neue Truppen Russland
ausgehoben hat im Laufe des Krieges, stellt man fest,
dass insgesamt eigentlich,
wenn alle überlebt hätten und alle noch da wären,
wären es irgendwie zwischen 1,2 und 1,3 Millionen.
Also es fehlen, in anderen Worten, es fehlen tatsächlich ungefähr 500.000 Soldaten,
die entweder dann gefallen, verwundet oder ausgeschieden sind.
Und in den 500.000 ist Wagner dann noch nicht mit drin und so andere Dinge.
Also insofern bestätigt diese Zahl halt die russischen Verluste in einer sehr hohen Größenordnung.
Und man geht davon aus, dass 200.000 mindestens gefallen sind,
das sind also 200.000 Tote bisher auf russischer Seite und wie gesagt eine halbe
Million Soldaten sind insgesamt mindestens ausgeschieden aus dem Krieg,
also russische Soldaten.
Also diese Zahlen sind natürlich nicht klar belegbar, sondern es gibt immer
wieder unterschiedliche Einschätzungen.
Es gibt die Zählung der Ukraine, die natürlich, sagen wir mal,
sehr aus ihrer eigenen Perspektive gefärbt sein dürfte.
Es gibt aber auch Untersuchungen von Gruppen, die in Russland Todesanzeigen, Beerdigungen,
all solche Parameter versuchen zu erheben oder die Gelder nehmen,
die der russische Staat an, wie nennt man das, Wiedergutmachungszahlungen für
gefallene Soldaten ausgibt, versuchen das irgendwie hochzurechnen.
Und da kommen die jetzt vielleicht nicht deckungsgleich übereinander,
aber die Größenordnungen scheinen schon zu stimmen.
Ja, also wahrscheinlich so 150.000
reguläre Truppen und 100.000 Wagner und ehemalige Territorial-Truppen,
also wesentlichen Ukrainer eigentlich auf russischer Seite aus den besetzten Gebieten,
die wahrscheinlich gefallen sein dürften.
Das, denke ich, ist wahrscheinlich eine realistische Schätzung.
Und wie gesagt, diese 500.000 fehlenden Soldaten kommt man zusammen,
wenn man so die russischen Zahlen nimmt und ein bisschen abzieht.
Aber dann sozusagen nach eigenen russischen Angaben fehlen 500.000 Soldaten.
Das sind jetzt keine ukrainischen Zahlen, sondern das sind alles russische Zahlen.
Man muss natürlich auch bedenken, wenn...
Verluste zu beklagen sind auf der russischen Seite, dann sind das gar nicht mal alles Russen.
Sondern das ist halt eine Mixtur aus schon sicherlich einer gewissen Zahl an
Russen, also jetzt auch Volksrussen, aber dann eben auch sehr viele andere Völker
der russischen Föderation.
Die ja, wie wir schon mehrfach berichtet haben, überproportional an diesem Krieg beteiligt sind.
Das heißt, diese ganze Soldatenakquise findet primär in all den Regionen statt, die nicht Moskau und St.
Petersburg und so russisches Kernland sind, sondern eben in den vorder- und
hinterasiatischen Regionen Russlands.
Dazu eben auch immer wieder Akquisen aus Afrika,
aus Syrien, also wo Russland überall hingeht bis hin zu Berichten,
dass halt irgendwie Studenten, die nach Russland gekommen sind,
um dort zu studieren, dann durch Tricks quasi überredet wurden,
da in den Krieg zu gehen mit irgendwelchen Geldversprechen, aber dann auch nur den Tod gefunden haben.
Das lässt sich jetzt zahlenmäßig natürlich jetzt nicht, keine Aussage zu machen,
was der Anteil ist, nur man kann nicht oft genug betonen, dass einfach Russland
hier eigentlich einen doppelten Vernichtungskrieg führt.
Nämlich auf der einen Seite gegenüber den Ukrainern, indem sie sie entweder
töten oder sogar auf der eigenen Seite dazu zwingen zu kämpfen.
In Donetsk und in Luhansk, aber auf der anderen Seite eben auch die nichtrussischen
Völker innerhalb der russischen Föderation,
die sie halt auch gleich dezimieren, um dann eben im Osten auch noch ihre weitere
Russifizierung vorantreiben zu können.
Das macht die ganze Sache so pervers und das kann man sich einfach immer wieder
alles gar nicht vorstellen, mit welcher Brutalität und mit welcher...
Inhumanität hier Russland vorgeht.
Dann ja, ein paar Tage, nachdem wir also unsere Sendung dann veröffentlicht haben,
also eine Woche später, um genau zu sein, es hatte sich schon abgezeichnet mit
ersten Meldungen, aber dann gab es dann tatsächlich eine neue Offensive.
Das heißt, die Russen haben dann im Norden, in der Nähe der Stadt Rakiv,
also im Oblast Rakiv in Richtung der Stadt Rakiv eine neue Offensive gestartet,
sind an zwei verschiedenen Stellen in die Ukraine neu eingedrungen und das machte
am Anfang alles einen sehr panischen Eindruck,
weil die Ukraine innerhalb von ein, zwei Tagen sehr viel Land quasi zurücklassen musste.
Das ist dann auch kritisiert worden, weil man sich ja gefragt hat,
jetzt habt ihr ja zwei Jahre Zeit gehabt, da Fortifications aufzubauen.
Nur man muss halt auch sehen, einerseits ist das Land, was da von den Russen
schnell überlaufen wurde, sehr dünn bis gar nicht besiedelt.
Das heißt, da gibt es einfach in dem Sinne keine natürlichen Infrastrukturelemente,
die man jetzt hätte nehmen können.
Einerseits und andererseits ist natürlich auch das Aufbauen direkt an der Grenze
immer sehr schwierig gewesen, weil man dann potenziell ja auch immer wieder
unter gelegentlichen Beschuss geriet.
Das heißt, die eigentlichen Stellungen, die eigentlichen Verteidigungsstellungen
scheinen etwas weiter hinten angesiedelt worden zu sein Und ich kann aber nicht ermessen,
inwiefern die Ukraine dann von diesen Vorstößen auch wirklich noch überrascht war.
Auf jeden Fall hatten sie dann innerhalb von ein paar Tagen zwei,
drei Kilometer und später dann fünf bis zehn Kilometer des Landes überschritten.
Aber dann ist die Abwehr so angestiegen, dass die Russen jetzt eigentlich auch
hier nicht weiterkommen.
Also es gab vor allem heftige Kämpfe in der Stadt Wofchansk.
Da fließt so ein Fluss durch den Ort.
Da sind die Russen über diesen Fluss nicht rübergekommen, auch nicht an der
vollen Breite bis zu diesem Fluss.
Die Russen haben versucht, verschiedene Brücken, auch weiter im Inland, zu übernehmen.
Zu zerstören, um eine entsprechende Nachlieferung von Truppen und Material zu
verhindern. Das ist den Russen so nicht gelungen.
Sprich, die Ukraine hat es jetzt geschafft, auch diese Offensive zurückzudrängen
oder zumindest erstmal einzudämmen.
Und ja, sieht auch da nicht so gut aus für die Russen. Also die Verluste sind dort ziemlich hoch.
Sie sind dann auch nur mit 30.000 Truppen gestartet, Was eigentlich eben ein
bisschen zu wenig erscheint, wenn das jetzt wirklich als Angriff auf die Stadt kreativ gedacht ist.
Ja, und sie sind dann sogar zwischenzeitlich in das Problem gelaufen,
dass sie einen Vorstoß gemacht haben mit zwischen 100 und 400 Soldaten,
die dann eine Zeit lang auch quasi nicht wirklich eingekesselt waren,
aber die isoliert waren und von der Versorgung abgeschnitten und auch dann Gefahr
liefen, in Gefangenschaft zu geraten.
Sie haben es dann wohl geschafft, dort den Kontakt wieder herzustellen,
aber das war auch über mehrere Tage eine kritische Situation,
wo Hunderte von Russen auf einmal hätten in Kriegsgefangenschaft geraten können.
Und es wurden auch wohl ein paar Dutzend Kriegsgefangene zumindest gemacht in
diesem Zusammenhang dann im Norden. Das ist auf jeden Fall bestätigt.
Ja, man fragt sich so ein bisschen, was die ganze Aktion sollte.
Also man hat so ein bisschen den Eindruck bekommen, Russland war dann von der
Entscheidung der USA, dann doch wieder die Unterstützung aufzunehmen,
etwas überrascht oder hat sich zumindest ausgemalt, dass man noch mehr Zeit hätte.
Der Vorstoß im Norden war also immer geplant gewesen, aber in dem Sinne war
der Truppenaufbau so noch nicht abgeschlossen. Trotzdem dachten sie halt,
jetzt läuft uns die Zeit weg, jetzt müssen wir hier in irgendeiner Form Fortschritte machen.
Das könnte eine der Kalkulationen gewesen sein, eine andere,
dass man eben auch die Ukraine vielleicht im Osten schwächen kann,
indem man sie zwingt im Norden Verstärkungen nachzuschieben.
Weiß man nicht, aber im Ergebnis war das wohl eine der schlechteren Ideen, die Russland hatte.
Es zeichnen sich so recht wenig Vorteile ab aus dieser Situation,
also sind da wirklich militärisch jetzt nicht weit gekommen,
aber dadurch, dass eben dieser Angriff möglich war und es vor allem den Ukrainern
nicht möglich war, direkt an der Grenze gegen die Russen vorzugehen,
Weil das ja bedeutet hätte,
sie hinter der Grenze auf russischem Gebiet mit den Waffen, die ihnen die Alliierten
bereitgestellt haben, zu bekämpfen.
Und das war ihnen ja nicht erlaubt. Denn es gibt ja nicht für alles,
aber für sehr viele Systeme oder gab es zumindest die Beschränkung mit so, ja könnt ihr ja machen,
könnt ihr auf die Russen werfen, könnt ihr in der Krim und in Donetsk und Luhansk, alles kein Problem,
weil die sind ja schon in eurem Land, aber bitte mal nicht auf dem eigentlichen
russischen Festland einsetzen.
Und das ist eine Beschränkung, die bisher schon immer ein Problem war.
Da aber eben so viele Russen auf ukrainischem Gebiet sind, gab es immer noch genug zu tun.
Aber jetzt in der Nordfront hat sich das einfach mal gezeigt,
dass es einfach absurd ist, dass die Ukraine sich dort nicht verteidigen kann.
Und selbstverständlich muss sie die Stellung hinter der Grenze angreifen,
weil da kommt die Logistik her, die Logistik muss man zerstören,
da stehen Artilleriesysteme, dort sind die Flugzeuge unterwegs.
Die dann halt aus sicherem Abstand die fetten Gleitbombs abwerfen,
die die Russen immer massiver zum Einsatz bringen und die wirklich ein großes Problem darstellen.
Und Ukraine hat sich einfach hingestellt und hat gesagt, Leute, geht's noch?
Wir müssen jetzt hier was machen. Und dann hat man richtig gemerkt,
wie dann so erst in Europa die Dominosteinchen umgefallen sind und der Druck immer größer wurde,
bis dann am Ende sogar die USA und damit dann auch endlich Deutschland eingesehen
hat, dass sich das so nicht mehr halten wird.
Und es gab dann eine, wie soll ich sagen, eine Liberalisierung der Waffennutzung.
Also es ist jetzt immer noch nicht so, dass die Ukraine machen kann,
was sie für richtig hält,
sondern für viele Waffengattungen wurde das sozusagen jetzt erlaubt in der Region
Kharkiv oder überall da,
wo die Russen aus Russland den Norden angreifen, das auch im russischen Festland einzusetzen.
Aber mit der Einschränkung, dass es eben bestimmte Waffengattungen nicht betrifft,
wie zum Beispiel Long-Range-Attack-Gims, die halt 300 Kilometer überbrücken
können, das unterbreitet.
Ist sozusagen noch außen vor, beziehungsweise weiß man nicht so genau,
die werden ja jetzt nicht jedes Detail gleich in die Öffentlichkeit geben,
aber man hat richtig gemerkt, wie so über einen Zeitraum von ein,
zwei Wochen dieser Widerstand da erst zerbröckelt ist und am Schluss komplett gefallen ist.
Und seitdem hat sich die Situation stabilisiert, ist aber auch noch nicht ideal.
Ja, also es gibt nach wie vor,
wie du es richtig sagtest, eine ganze Menge Einschränkungen,
auch welche Art von Zielen sie bekämpfen dürfen und so mit bestimmten Waffen
und in welchen Gegenden.
Also sie sind da nicht völlig frei, die Waffen so einzusetzen,
wie es am effektivsten wäre, leider.
Aber auf jeden Fall deutlicher Fortschritt und man kann davon ausgehen,
dass dann sozusagen die Beschränkungen jetzt wahrscheinlich nach und nach auch wegfallen werden.
Aber natürlich, warum einfach, wenn es auch kompliziert geht.
Ja immer so ein Ein Ausbalancieren einer wahrgenommenen Eskalationsgefahr.
Genau. Der Begriff dafür, was dort gemacht wird, lautet Eskalationsmanagement. Ja, genau.
So, da muss man sich natürlich immer erstmal fragen, okay, was bitte soll hier noch eskaliert werden?
Ja, ich meine, wir erleben hier eigentlich den totalen Krieg.
Klar, und was natürlich im Raum steht,
ist immer die Ausweitung der Waffengattung,
sprich Atomdiskussion hatten wir ja hier schon, auf der einen Seite und auf
der anderen Seite halt potenziell andere Angriffsszenarien auf NATO-Länder.
Das ist sozusagen Teil der Debatte, ich halte beides nicht für sonderlich realistisch, aber...
Andere Meinungen, andere Maßnahmen.
Ja, man hat manchmal den Eindruck sozusagen, man würde sich einem totalen Krieg nähern.
Aber das ist nicht wirklich der Fall, sondern Russland ist sozusagen nur zu
80 oder 90 Prozent unser Feind.
So mit 10, 20 Prozent kooperiert der Westen weiterhin mit Russland.
Also zum Beispiel, gestern gehört, dass die Nahrungsmittelimporte der EU aus
Russland in 2023 einen neuen Rekord erreicht haben.
Ja, so.
Und auch in anderen Bereichen.
Also es gibt nach wie vor noch Zusammenarbeit und Handel, auch wenn es immer weniger wird.
Aber es ist nicht so, dass das jetzt alles umfassen würde. Es gibt nach wie
vor, gibt es erstaunlicherweise Handel mit Russland, also Westen aus,
so in bestimmten Bereichen.
Ja, ich bezog das jetzt eigentlich auch mehr auf die reine militärische Komponente.
Also Eskalation, meine klar, ich glaube auch Frankreich hat jetzt bis vor kurzem
noch LNG-Gas aus Russland bezogen.
Und ich weiß gerade gar nicht, wie die Situation mit Österreich ist.
Auch die Gasdurchleitungsverträge sind noch nicht komplett ausgelaufen.
Das wird dann glaube ich erst nächstes Jahr, also die durch die Ukraine laufen wohlgemerkt.
Es ist eh absurd, man hat jetzt auch sehr viel Umgehungsdynamik über Kasachstan
und andere Ex-Sowjet-Republiken, Usbekistan, wo auf einmal der Handel mit Deutschland explodiert.
Ja, so, kaum sind die Sanktionen da. Klar, also die Komponente gibt es auch.
Rede ich aber jetzt gar nicht drüber. Ich meine jetzt das rein militärische
Bedrohungspotenzial, wo man ja immer sagt, Eskalation könnte ja bedeuten,
dass wir noch tiefer in den Krieg gezogen werden.
So, das ist ja immer die Formulierung. Und natürlich könnten wir natürlich noch
tiefer in den Krieg gezogen werden.
Ich finde nur, wir tun auch gerade alles dafür, damit es so ist und,
Hätten wir viele der Maßnahmen vorher ergriffen, dann wäre es nicht so egal.
Tatsache ist, es ist immer ein Hin und Her,
aber mit jeder Maßnahme, die Russland dann ergreift, die dann wieder mal nicht
geht, wie zum Beispiel jetzt eben dieser Angriff aus Belgorod Richtung Kharkiv,
ist der Westen dann wieder an diesem Punkt so, ach naja gut,
also wenn ihr das jetzt so macht, dann legen wir auch noch eine Schippe drauf.
Und so bröckeln diese ganzen Zurückhaltungen.
Wir werden es auch gleich nochmal hören, wenn wir über die Diskussion über Truppen
in der Ukraine, Ausbildung etc.
Reden werden. Aber machen wir vielleicht erstmal kurz die militärische Situation zu Ende.
Aber militärisch passt noch eine Sache,
die ich erwähnen möchte, die so ein bisschen im Westen, glaube ich,
auch untergegangen ist oder wo generell die Medien sich zurückhalten,
die Mainstream-Medien.
Und das sind so die diversen, ich sag mal, russischen Provokationen auf NATO-Gebiet.
Ich meine, gab es halt schon immer, dass man Flugzeuge schickt,
die jetzt den Luftraum verletzen.
Also neulich sind da Bomber der Russen im Baltischen Meer in den schwedischen
Luftraum eingedrungen.
Aber das Krasseste, was Russland gebracht
hat, war, dass sie jetzt einen Cruise-Missile-Angriff gestartet haben,
wo die Rakete nach Polen reingeflogen ist.
Und dann umgedreht hat und sozusagen von polnischer Seite aus in die Ukraine
zurückgeflogen ist und dort eingeschlagen ist.
Also sie war für ein paar Minuten sozusagen im polnischen Luftraum.
Und die Ukrainer waren natürlich so mittelbegeistert davon.
Da wurde immer gefragt, ey, wäre vielleicht nett gewesen, wenn ihr das Ding
vorher abgeschossen hättet, bevor das Ding wieder zurück in die Ukraine geflogen
ist und sogar, ich glaube,
ein oder zwei Menschen dann getötet hat.
Also das ist halt auch so eine Situation. Plus diverse Sabotageaktionen,
die nicht erwähnt werden.
Finanzierung von Terrorgruppen und, und, und. Also da läuft halt auch viel auf
kleiner Ebene unter dem Radar, wo Russland versucht,
auch eine Reaktion der NATO zu provozieren, wobei die NATO sich in der Regel
zurückhält mit dann militärischen Antworten, weil sie der Meinung sind,
das ist genau das, was Russland will.
So nach dem Motto, oh und jetzt die NATO,
sondern deswegen sagen sie sich, okay, lassen wir die mal machen,
aber über kurz oder lang wird man natürlich trotzdem auch hier vielleicht noch
mehr antworten müssen, beziehungsweise die Antwort im Moment sieht halt so aus, dass man einfach sagt,
okay, lass sie ruhig da rumfliegen, wir liefern stattdessen einfach mehr Waffen.
So das ist im Moment quasi die Antwort des Westens, aber ja.
Das ist natürlich auch eine der politischen Debatten, die noch geführt wird,
die wir jetzt noch nicht so auf der Liste hatten, dass halt auch gefragt wird,
okay, warum sollen wir denn nicht sozusagen von Polen und von Rumänien aus,
ich glaube auf Ungarn muss man da nicht setzen,
den Westteil der Ukraine mit den eigenen Patriot-Systemen bewachen.
Dass wenn sozusagen dort Angriffe sind und Cruise Mussels ins Land fliegen,
dass man die eben auch mit den Patriot-Systemen oder anderen Flugabwehrsystemen, die dort stehen,
aus dem Grenzgebiet mit abschießen soll.
Das wäre natürlich eine deutlich involviertere Beteiligung, aber ist eine der Debatten.
Und das würde natürlich der Ukraine helfen, weil ein Patriot-System,
was auf der anderen Seite des Zauns steht und trotzdem in der Lage ist,
einen Bereich von 300, 400, 500 Kilometern abzudecken, ist natürlich genauso
gut wie ein Patriot-System, was 20 Meter weiter im Osten auf ukrainischem Gebiet steht.
Ja, das ist alles sehr schwierig.
Kurz oder lang durch diese Rakiv-Offensive ist also die nächste Beschränkung gefallen.
Die skandinavischen Länder und wenig überraschend die baltischen Länder,
die waren da relativ schnell dabei und haben gesagt, es gibt keine Restriktionen.
Auch Frankreich und UK haben gesagt, es gibt jetzt keine Restriktionen.
Das gilt ja dann immerhin für diese Sculp Missiles bzw.
Storm Shadow, das ist ja dasselbe System.
Also die können sie zum Einsatz bringen, auch wenn sie das meines Wissens bisher
im Norden auch noch gar nicht getan haben.
Und natürlich gibt es auch immer noch keine Taurus-Lieferungen in Deutschland.
Deutschland ist aber erstmal damit beschäftigt, überhaupt Taurus einsatzfähig zu machen.
Machen das immerhin, also da gibt es jetzt Modernisierungsbestrebungen,
dass halt irgendwie vielleicht auch die andere Hälfte von den 600,
die man auf Lager hat, dann auch wirklich benutzbar sind, wenn man sie dann
wirklich mal benutzen würde oder wollen würde.
Ach ja, na gut.
Aber es gibt auch diverse Erfolge der Ukraine nach wie vor.
Also so schwierig die Situation on the ground ist, umso besser sind dann die
Fortschritte in der Luft und auch auf See.
Erstmal hat die Ukraine ihre ganze Kampagne voranschreiten lassen mit Angriffen
auf die Öl- und Gasinfrastruktur in Russland.
Da kommen ja die zahlreichen Drohnen vor allem zum Einsatz.
Hier und da vielleicht auch mal eine Rakete, das weiß man ja ganz genau,
weil das sind so koordinierte Angriffe.
Aber meistens sind es solche Drohnen, das heißt man hat so einen Drohnenschwarm, dann fliegen dann 30,
40 Drohnen los und greifen verschiedene Ziele gleichzeitig an,
auch um die Luftabwehrsysteme dort busy zu halten und immer wieder gelingt es,
also immer wieder im Sinne von nahezu täglich brennt irgendeine Öl- oder Gasinfrastruktur.
Also Raffinerien, wo halt aus Öl Benzin diese oder ähnlich,
also vor allem glaube ich Benzin hergestellt wird oder Silos und es gibt fast
keinen Standort, glaube ich, der noch nicht in irgendeiner Form ins Auge gefasst wurde.
Also das ist halt in zunehmendem Maße für die Russen ein Problem,
weil die einfach die ganze Zeit da mit dem Löschen nicht nachkommen.
Es gibt gerade einen Angriff da bei Rostov-on-Don in der Stadt Azov,
da hat es dann irgendwie drei Tage gebrannt, weil sie es einfach auch irgendwie
nicht gelöscht bekommen haben.
Das ist auf jeden Fall für die Russen ein großes Problem und es sterben vor
allem in letzter Zeit sehr viele Luftabwehrsysteme der Russen,
also vor allem auf der Krim.
S-300, S-400 und neuerdings gibt es jetzt glaube ich auch S-500 Systeme,
die ersten, die Russland zum Einsatz bringt.
Da bin ich mir jetzt gerade gar nicht so sicher, ob das auch schon zerstört wurde.
Habe ich jetzt nicht so ganz in Erinnerung. Tatsache ist, sehr viele Luftabwehrsysteme
sind bei Drohnen- und Raketenangriffen in den letzten zwei Monaten zerstört worden.
Ich wage gar nicht jetzt hier eine Zahl aufzurufen, aber es waren extrem viele.
Man muss dazu sagen, Russland hat aber auch extrem viele davon,
nur sie müssen halt die auch am laufenden Meter nachliefern,
um überhaupt noch in irgendeiner Form der Drohnenangriffe Herr zu werden.
Und es gibt jetzt auch wieder vermehrt Erfolge beim Bekämpfen von Kampfjets.
Also es sind glaube ich mindestens drei SU-25 zerstört worden in der Luft und
dann eins ist glaube ich von alleine runtergefallen und SU-34 mussten auch noch ein paar dran glauben.
Und absoluter Höhepunkt durch einen Drohnen- oder Raketenangriff,
ich glaube es war so eine Neptun-Rakete, eine modifizierte, die jetzt auch 1000
Kilometer kann, haben es die Ukrainer geschafft,
an einem Standort tief in Russland auch zwei SU-57 zu zerstören.
Das ist dahingehend bemerkenswert, dass die SU-57 sozusagen der allermodernste,
sogenannte Fifth Generation Kampfjet der Russen ist.
Also das, was sie sozusagen der F-35 entgegensetzen wollen, auch wenn es da
arge Zweifel gibt im Westen, dass die überhaupt auf Augenhöhe betrachtet werden können.
Nichtsdestotrotz, davon haben sie überhaupt nur 22 Stück, soweit man weiß.
Und zwei davon sind mindestens bei diesem Angriff kaputt gegangen.
Also auch da findet eine Dezimierung statt.
Man muss aber auch sagen, die Luftflotte der Russen ist relativ groß.
Und ich glaube, dass nicht mehr als 10 oder 15 Prozent bisher davon zerstört wurden.
Nur diese Luftflotte ist ja nicht nur für die Ukraine da, sondern die schützt
ja sozusagen ganz Russland. Und man merkt, dass das die auf jeden Fall über
kurz oder lang dann auch vor Probleme stellen könnte.
Ja, noch kurz zu den Angriffen auf die Öl- und Gasinfrastruktur.
Die haben jetzt dazu geführt, dass in Russland die Benzinpreise an den Tankstellen
deutlich angezogen sind.
Also es funktioniert wohl so, in Russland die Preise werden staatlich festgelegt
und dann zahlt der Staat den Unternehmen sozusagen den Differenzpreis,
also subventioniert das Ganze.
Nur ist jetzt der Abstand zwischen, oder die Zahlungen, die Russland leisten
musste in 2023, sind schon explodiert.
Und jetzt in den ersten Monaten 2024 haben sie sich, glaube ich,
vervierfacht, weshalb sich dann eben die russische Regierung auch gezwungen sah,
an den Zapfsäulen die Preise zu erhöhen, weil sie es sich nicht mehr leisten konnten,
so viel zu subventionieren.
Ja, also es ist nicht alles ohne Schwierigkeiten für Russland.
Russische Kriegstaktik passt sich allerdings auch an, muss man sagen.
Also weiterhin gibt es sehr viele Angriffe auf fossile Kraftwerke,
was Ukraine jetzt übrigens auch damit kontert, dass sie jetzt in Zukunft mehr
auf Windenergie gehen wollen.
Das hat man glaube ich auch schon mal erwähnt, dass dieser Krieg dazu führen
kann, dass sozusagen die Ukraine dann auch im Schnelltempo auf regenerative Energien setzt,
weil sie natürlich jetzt auch die Fragilität dieser Systeme auch sieht.
Ich meine klar, man kann auch Windkraftwerke zerstören, gar keine Frage.
Nur das sind sehr viele kleinteiligere Angriffe, die da erforderlich sind,
als man einem einzelnen Strike auf ein riesiges Kraftwerk, wenn man da ins Herz trifft, erreicht.
Reicht und dieser Umbau muss ja nun ohnehin erfolgen.
Inwiefern es jetzt der Ukraine gelingt, die Infrastruktur wieder für den Winter
fit zu machen, das wird man dann sehen. Wird auf jeden Fall dran gearbeitet.
Russen haben auch ein bisschen perfide Taktiken wieder an den Start gebracht, wie zum Beispiel,
Angriffe auf Wohngebiete oder in Bomben oder Drohnen reinfliegen und dann wartet
man nochmal zwei Stunden, bis die ganzen
Helfer da sind und versuchen dort zu retten, was zu retten ist,
um dann dieselbe Stelle nochmal anzugreifen und die Helfer sozusagen auch noch
gleich mit Leidenschaft zu ziehen.
Das sind immer so Meldungen, wo man sich halt auch immer wieder denkt, oh Mann, geht's noch?
Ja und es sind aber nicht nur jetzt fossile Kraftwerke, sondern auch Wasserkraftwerke
und Dämme, die weiterhin beschossen werden.
Also das kommt noch dazu.
Und Flughäfeninfrastruktur wird auch angegriffen, was natürlich insofern erstmal
überrascht, weil Flughäfen ja gar nicht so eine große Rolle spielen bisher.
Allerdings, da reden wir gleich nochmal drüber, werden ja nun bald die F-16
im Einsatz erwartet und dafür ist eine bessere Infrastruktur erforderlich,
weil diese modernen Flugzeuge nicht überall starten können und man braucht eben
möglichst viele Orte und es wird vermutet, dass das eben auch damit was zu tun haben kann.
Insgesamt glaube ich, haben die aber schon langfristig ein Materialproblem, die Russen.
Es gibt jetzt Fotos von der finnischen Grenze, wo man sieht,
dass einfach dort nahezu 80 Prozent der Soldaten offensichtlich abgezogen sind,
weil es kaum noch Fahrzeuge, kaum noch Personen gibt auf diesen Fotos.
Und auch was da so an Fahrzeugen rumstand, ist komplett abgezogen worden.
Also die große Angst der NATO-Erweiterung und der finnischen Grenze,
so groß scheint sie dann doch nicht zu sein, wenn man jetzt quasi alles dort abzieht.
Ja und es gibt in dem Zusammenhang auch wohl neue verlässlichere Zahlen zur
russischen Panzerproduktion Und zwar sieht es so aus,
dass wohl Russland im letzten Jahr in der Größenordnung von tausend Panzern
neu an die Front geliefert hat,
aber 800 bis 900 davon waren eben aufbereitete, bereits existierende ältere Panzer aus ihren Basen.
Das heißt, dass die russische Panzerproduktion pro Jahr an wirklich komplett
neuen Panzern irgendwo zwischen 100 und 200 sich aktuell bewegt.
Aber weil eben noch, weil sie sich darauf konzentrieren, jetzt noch viel,
sagen, altes Material dann an die Front zu bringen, so konnten sie ungefähr
1000 Panzer im letzten Jahr ersetzen oder neu an den Start bringen.
Haben aber deutlich mehr verloren. Also das ist definitiv für sie ein Minusgeschäft,
davon kann man ausgehen.
Wir kommen gleich nochmal zu den Waffen, vielleicht noch eine Sache,
die ich ganz lustig fand, wobei mit lustig ist es ja in so einem Konflikt immer
so eine Sache, aber man muss ja irgendwie sich auch auf positive Sachen konzentrieren können.
Also es gab so eine Taktik der Ukraine, dass sie mit Drohnen ukrainische Flaggen
verteilt haben und das haben sie irgendwie, ich weiß nicht ganz genau wie die beschaffen waren,
aber sie haben es geschafft diese Flaggen mit Drohnen abzusetzen und dann standen
die halt irgendwie, ich weiß nicht ob das magnetisch war oder mit Seilen.
Ich glaube es gab auch eine Konstruktion, wo die Flagge dann sozusagen nach
unten hängt mit dem Gewicht, also quasi andersrum.
Und das haben sie dann so an so strategischen Orten in der Nähe von russischen Positionen gemacht.
Und dann fühlten sich die Russen aber immer wieder bemüht, einen Trupp loszuschicken,
um diese Flagge dann wieder einzusammeln, weil das ja nicht geht.
Und dann haben sie das abgewartet und dort Gegenangriffe gestartet,
wenn die versucht haben, irgendwie ihre Flaggen zu entfernen, sozusagen so als Bait.
Ja, eine andere Sache, die ich jetzt noch beobachtet habe im Zusammenhang mit
Drohnen, eine neue Taktik oder Taktik, die seit einer Weile gefahren wird,
weiß nicht, ob wir das schon erwähnt hatten, ich glaube nicht,
dass die Ukraine mittlerweile mit Drohnen-Geschwadern angreift.
Also nicht in dem Sinne,
dass es eben ein großes Mutterschiff gibt und das dann FPW-Drohnen entweder
aussetzt oder von FPW-Drohnen begleitet wird und dadurch zum einen die Reichweite
der FPW-Drohnen erhöht,
aber vermutlich auch als Relaisstation fungiert,
um sozusagen in dem punktgestörten Environment die FPW-Drohnen dann besser zu steuern können,
indem sozusagen eine Drohne als Relaisstation dient und gleichzeitig als Beobachtung
von oben dann das Ganze leitet und sie dann eben mit mehreren FPW-Drohnen dann
angreifen, während die große,
teure Drohne halt von oben zuschaut und den Einsatz leitet, wenn man so will. Ziemlich abgefahren.
Jo, vielleicht noch einen Satz zur Mobilisierung.
Das war ja auch ein Thema in den letzten Monaten, inwiefern die Ukraine in der
Lage ist, ihre Mobilisierung voranzutreiben.
Während man es in Russland im Wesentlichen mit Geld macht, ist es in der Ukraine
ein bisschen anders gelagert.
Und es gab jetzt allerdings auch ein Angebot an Gefangene.
Wir erinnern uns ja, das war ja so diese Prigorschin-Wagner-Methode,
sich in russischen Gefängnissen die Schwerverbrecher zu holen und die an die
Front zu schicken nach dem Motto,
wenn ihr es überlebt nach sechs Monaten, dann seid ihr frei.
Da sind ja sehr viele Leute verheizt worden.
Auch das eine interessante Methode sozusagen die Gefängnisse leer zu bekommen und Platz zu machen.
Jetzt hat auch die Ukraine ein Angebot angefangen gemacht der Armee beizutreten
und wenn sie sich verpflichten dann entsprechend ihre Haftzeit zu verkürzen.
Es gibt aber einen kleinen Unterschied, also anders als in Russland werden hier
keine Schwerverbrecher, also keine Mörder oder so dieses Angebot gemacht,
sondern nehmen wir an irgendwelche anderen, ich weiß jetzt nicht ganz genau
wie der Katalog ist, aber auf jeden Fall keine Schwerverbrecher und das hat
wohl irgendwie so 3000 weitere Rekruten bekommen.
Und ansonsten ist es halt einfach ein bisschen schwierig, die Ausbildung ist
auch noch ein Flaschenhals,
aber vor allem haben sich ja auch viele junge Männer der Ukraine den Rücken
gekehrt und man muss schauen,
wie das dort weitergeht.
Kommen wir zum Waffensystem, ist ja auch nochmal immer so ein Thema,
weil der ganze Krieg sehr davon geprägt ist, dass man immer sieht,
die eine Seite rüstet in der Hinsicht auf und die andere muss dann ein taktisches Gegenmittel finden.
Und es ist auch so, dass eben auch das, was die Ukraine alles zum Einsatz gebracht
hat, durchaus auf eine gewisse Reaktion bei den Russen gestoßen ist.
Wir haben das ja auch schon ein paar Mal besprochen.
Electronic Warfare ist hier so ein Thema, also Jamming von Signalen macht dem
einen oder anderen Waffensystem dann doch schon Ärger.
Wie geht es hier weiter? Also wir haben ja schon besprochen,
Russland verliert derzeit sehr viel Material.
Also sie verlieren wirklich sehr viele Fahrzeuge, sehr viele Panzer,
sehr viele gepanzerte Infanteriefahrzeuge, Trucks, alles mögliche.
Also das können die gar nicht, da sind sie gar nicht in der Lage,
das alles so zu produzieren.
Also die Schätzung darüber, wie lange dieser Vorrat hält, die gehen auseinander.
Aber ich glaube, man kann schon sagen, länger als zwei Jahre kann Russland das so nicht durchhalten.
Aber die Ukraine ist jetzt halt auch dabei aufzurüsten, demnächst sollen ja
die F-16 Kampfjets dazukommen.
Da geht die Ausbildung auch voran und es gibt auch schon die ersten Gruppen,
die ausgebildet wurden.
Aber die Ukraine bemängelt, dass halt nicht genug Kapazität in den USA vor allem
bereit ist, zur Verfügung gestellt werden kann, um weitere Piloten auszubilden.
Man braucht ja pro Flugzeug ungefähr zwei Piloten, um so ein Flugzeug auszulassen.
Also die fliegen nicht zusammen, sondern zusammen.
Die müssen ja auch mal schlafen und trotzdem wollen sie ja immer in irgendeiner
Form in der Lage sein, mit so einem Kampfjet aufzusteigen.
Gar nicht mal nur, um Angriffe zu fliegen, sondern vor allem,
was ich vermute, was sie zunächst einmal tun werden, ist, dass das F-16 vor
allem als defensive Maßnahme gemacht wird.
Also zur Zerstörung heranfliegender Cruise Missiles oder eben auch zur Zerstörung
heranfliegender anderer Kampfjets, die Bomben abwerfen sollen.
Das wird sich zeigen, das weiß derzeit keiner so ganz genau, was dort gemacht wird.
Ja, auf jeden Fall hat aber dieses Projekt Unterstützung bekommen aus Schweden, weil dort zwei,
was ist das, Saab 340 AEW,
sogenannte AVEX Flugzeuge, also so fliegende Radarstationen,
die jetzt nicht so groß sind wie diese Riesen-AVEX,
die man so kennt auf Boeing-Flugzeugen, auf 747 und so weiter.
Von den Amerikanern, sondern eher so kleinere Flugzeuge, die aber in der Lage
sind, die Ukraine ganz gut abzudecken.
Das heißt, diese beiden Flugzeuge, die Schweden liefern wird,
werden dann sozusagen Teil dieses Verteidigungssystems werden.
Die haben statt oben jetzt, wie wir es von den klassischen Airbags kennen,
nicht, also diese klassischen Airbags haben ja oben so eine runde Schüssel oder
so eine Untertasse oben drauf geschraubt mit einem rotierenden Radar.
Diese SARPs sind zum einen Turboprops und haben eben oben einen Riegel draufgeschraubt.
Und das ist halt so ein Solid-State-Radar.
Das ungefähr eine Reichweite von 350 Kilometern hat und eben den Strahl elektronisch lenken kann.
Und Nachteil ist so ein bisschen, dass es vorne und hinten so was wie Blindspots hat.
Aber das ist jetzt nicht so schlimm, wenn du sowieso an der Grenze entlang fliegst
oder so. Aber ja, sehr nützliche und leistungsfähige Geräte auf jeden Fall.
Ja, wie schon erwähnt, Infrastruktur für die F-16, da bin ich sehr gespannt,
wie sich das entwickelt, weil das ist halt kritisch.
Die brauchen für die F-16 wirklich sehr viele Landeplätze.
Das hatte ich ja vorhin schon erwähnt mit den Flughäfen, dass das ein Grund
ist, warum die Russen Flughäfen jetzt angreifen, um zu verhindern,
dass es eben entsprechende Infrastruktur gibt für die F-16, weil ich glaube,
die haben schon ein bisschen Schiss vor den F-16. Das ist definitiv so ein Ding.
Was so ein bisschen heikel ist noch, ist, worauf es halt jetzt hinauslaufen wird wohl, ist,
dass der Großteil der Wartung in Polen passieren wird von den F-16.
Das heißt, dass sie halt regelmäßig über die Grenze fliegen müssen,
um gewartet zu werden und das halt auch
dann wieder so ein gewisses Eskalationspotenzial hat, sagen wir es mal so.
Ja, macht natürlich total Sinn, weil für die Russen es nicht so einfach wird,
jetzt in Polen dann eine F-16 zu zerstören.
Beziehungsweise einfach die Infrastruktur in der Ukraine aufzubauen,
die dann vermutlich auch primäres Ziel sein wird.
Weil die Russen natürlich dann gerne Propagandaerfolge haben.
Hier F-16 zerstört und so.
Die F-16 oder auch nur die Infrastruktur für die F-16.
Ja, also das zeichnet sich wohl auch ab. Und möglicherweise sind auch schon
erste F-16 tatsächlich in der Ukraine.
Offiziell ist das zwar nicht, aber es wurden wohl diverse Überflüge von Kampfflugzeugen
von Polen in die Ukraine beobachtet.
Von Anna unter anderem, die dort lebt.
Also meiste Anna in Ukraine, die mit dem YouTube-Kanal.
Ja, also das ist nach wie vor ein Thema für den Spätsommer, denke ich mal.
Und wir werden erst davon wirklich erfahren, wenn diese Flugzeuge auch das erste
Mal richtig zugeschlagen haben und es sich dann nicht mehr groß leugnen lässt, dass die da sind.
Ja, aber ich erwarte davon nicht sehr viel.
Niemand erwartet davon jetzt allzu viel. Dafür sind die Zahlen auch erstmal
an Flugzeugen nicht groß genug, weil eigentlich bräuchte die Ukraine ungefähr 500 davon.
Und es kommen wahrscheinlich jetzt erstmal zwischen 5 und 20. so.
Ja, das ist richtig, aber erinnerst du dich noch, als wir diese Serie an Abschüssen
von SO-34 Kampfflugzeugen hatten?
Da gab es im Prinzip zwei Thesen im Raum. Die eine, die vermutlich die richtige
war, ist dieses mobile Patriot-System,
was halt in der Lage war, das Ding zu erfassen und dann eine entsprechende Abwehrrakete
loszuschicken, der dieser SM-34 nicht entgehen konnte.
Die zweite These war, dass es
doch schon F-16-Systeme gibt, die im Prinzip ähnlich funktionieren können.
Das heißt, eine F-16 kann so einen Effekt haben wie so ein mobiles Patriot-System,
weil sie eben über die Radarfähigkeiten verfügen kann, diese SO-34 zu detektieren
und aber auch über die Air-to-Air-Missile-Kapazität zum Abschuss dieser Flugzeuge verfügt.
Also ich sehe halt die F-16 primär erstmal als Verteidigungssystem und da können
natürlich auch fünf F-16 einen Unterschied machen, wenn sie dann genauso effizient
zum Einsatz kommen wie zum Beispiel so ein Patriot-System.
Also es werden natürlich neue Fähigkeiten damit kommen.
Und eine tatsächlich, wie du richtig sagst, interessante neue Fähigkeit wird sein,
diese Harm Anti-Radiation Missiles, also die zur Bekämpfung von Flugabwehrsystemen
oder anderen Funkstationen.
Also alles, was Funk ausstrahlt, kann ja von denen angepeilt werden.
Und wie konnten Sie zwar bisher auch an Ihren SUs reagieren.
Aber nur in einem sehr eingeschränkten, vorprogrammierten Mode.
Was sie jetzt mit der F-16 dann können, sind sogenannte Search-and-Destroy-Missionen.
Wo sie dann hochfliegen, dafür sorgen,
dass die Russen ihr Radar einschalten und dann quasi in der Luft dann detektieren,
ah, hier wurde jetzt ein Radar eingeschaltet.
Die Spezifikationen von dem Signal direkt in der Luft in diese Harmmissile zu
laden und die dann in wenigen Sekunden eigentlich neu zu targeten auf ein unbekanntes
Ziel, was dort gerade hochgepoppt ist.
Und das könnte sicherlich eine sehr interessante Fähigkeit sein,
die auf jeden Fall mit dazu kommt,
plus eben neue Luft-Luft-Raketen, die zur Flugabwehr dienen, die dadurch,
dass sie halt aus einer größeren Höhe und mit einer gewissen Anfangsgeschwindigkeit
schon abgeschossen werden können, eine höhere Reichweite haben.
Als jetzt, wenn man gleich große Raketen vom Boden aus abschießt.
Also sie haben dann eben ein deutlich besseres Profil.
Also das sind mit Sicherheit zwei ganz wichtige Fähigkeiten.
Plus die Dinger kommen mit sehr modernen Radaren, sodass sie zwischen 100 und
150 Kilometer Reichweite haben und aus der Entfernung dann eben russische Kampfflugzeuge
auch erfassen und bekämpfen können.
Ja, Macron hat dann auch sehr überraschend angekündigt,
auch aus dem französischen Luftwaffenprogramm noch Flugzeuge in die Ukraine zu liefern.
Konkret geht es dabei um sogenannte Mirage 2000-5 Flugzeuge,
die so ein bisschen 90er Jahre Technologie sind und offenbar demnächst auch
ausgemustert werden sollten oder sollen.
Und jetzt mustern sie sie sozusagen in die Ukraine aus.
Das ist ja so ein Schema, was wir überall sehen. Also auch die ganzen F-16s,
die jetzt in die Ukraine marschieren, werden durch F-35 ersetzt.
Also diese ganzen Waffenlieferungen sind
ja im Wesentlichen eigentlich ein Modernisierungsprogramm für den Westen.
Und ja, offensichtlich gibt es auch keinen Bedarf dafür.
Inwiefern die Ukraine da einen großen Nutzen von haben kann, weiß ich nicht.
Es sind erstmal nicht so mega viele von diesen Flugzeugen verfügbar.
Ich habe jetzt gerade keine große Zahl, aber es war irgendwas niedrig zweistelliges
und auch hier muss natürlich dann erstmal wieder ein Piloten-Ausbildungsprogramm gestartet werden.
Da müssen dann entsprechende Infrastrukturmaßnahmen ergriffen werden.
Aber ich denke mal, die Ukraine sagt gar nicht Nein dazu zu und wird die schon
in irgendeiner Form zu irgendeinem Zeitpunkt übernehmen.
Ja, da kann man eben auch so ziemlich alles dran schrauben oder sehr viel dran
schrauben, so an westlichen Waffen und,
ja, und es ist eigentlich ein ganz brauchbarer Abfangjäger, wie gesagt,
auch nicht mehr das allerneueste, aber wahrscheinlich auch auch nicht so viel
schlechter als der F-16.
Ja, und auf jeden Fall besser als der alte russische Kram, den sie noch haben,
der halt ohnehin irgendwann an Ersatzteilen leiden wird, weil aus Russland kriegen sie bestimmt keine.
Ja, dann hat die Ukraine gesagt, dass sie wohl ganz gute Erfahrungen mit diesen
Small Diameter Bombs haben.
Also das ist ja quasi auch diese Gleitbombe, Bombenaufsatz für normale,
dumme Projektile, die halt vom Flugzeug aus abgeworfen werden.
Wir hatten glaube ich zuletzt über die GL die Ground Launch Variante gesprochen,
wo du meintest, die wären Jamming anfällig. Das ist jetzt wohl bei diesen nicht so.
Ja, dann sind auch die Attackams ja auch freigesetzt worden.
Also ich weiß gar nicht, ob wir das hier besprochen hatten, aber die USA haben
ja dann auch irgendwann eingesehen, dass auch die Beschränkungen,
Also ich glaube mit den Waffen, genau mit den neuen Waffenlieferungen kam nicht
nur sehr viel Attackams Munition,
sondern es kamen jetzt auch die Attackams, also Attackams sind diese sehr leistungsfähigen
ballistischen Raketen, die man mit diesen Highmass Launchern starten kann.
Also wo man nicht sechs einzelne losschickt, sondern in so einem Paket quasi
nur eine drin ist und die ist aber dann richtig fett.
Die wollte die Ukraine ja immer haben, kam dann auch irgendwann,
aber in sehr limitierter Menge und eben auch nur in der 150 Kilometer Variante
und mittlerweile gibt es eben auch die 300 Kilometer Variante.
Die dann eben sehr viel tiefer in der Ukraine reinschlagen konnte und dort auch
so einiges platt gemacht hat auf den Landebahnen und ist glaube ich auch zum
Einsatz gekommen gegen die S-300,
S-400 Luftabwehrsysteme dort etc.
Und mittlerweile gibt es wohl auch einen Vorfall, wo ein Kriegsschiff mit Attack-Gims
zerstört wurde Und zwar mit einer Variante, die einen 470 Kilogramm Warhead
hat, was auch nochmal eine Größenordnung ist, die es so bisher nicht gab.
Es gibt ja immer diese ganzen einzelnen Missiles und Projektile in tausend verschiedenen
Varianten und offensichtlich haben die USA also jetzt ihr Silo jetzt mal komplett aufgemacht.
Und ich habe so den Eindruck, dass mittlerweile alles, was diese Serie quasi
bietet in der Ukraine jetzt auch zum Einsatz kommt.
Aber natürlich nicht im Norden, weil das dann wiederum zu gefährlich.
Während die Russen diese Gleitbombs sehr erfolgreich einsetzten,
gab es jetzt auch die Meldung, dass wohl auch die Ukraine ihre eigenen Gleitbombs entwickeln möchte.
Also man darf ja nie vergessen, auch Ukraine war ja schon immer ein Waffenproduzent
und zwar für die gesamte Sowjetunion auch ein sehr wichtiger Teil.
Sehr viel der Waffen, die quasi jetzt gegen die Ukraine eingesetzt werden,
sind ursprünglich mal dort entwickelt und gebaut worden.
Und da geht also das Rennen jetzt weiter, muss man mal schauen,
was das so bringt und sie haben auch ihre Neptun-Raketen, mit denen sie ja ganz
am Anfang die Moskwa versenkt haben, da war die ja noch brandneu,
auch die haben sie jetzt eben auf 1000 Kilometer Reichweite ersetzt,
und ich hatte ja vorhin schon erwähnt, das Abschießen der SU-57 geht offensichtlich auf die Kappe.
Ja, sie haben vor allen Dingen neue Software,
auch das Ground-Attack-Mode, dass sie eben auch Bodenziele angreifen können
mit der Rakete, jetzt so wie Russland es auch mit seinen S-300 gemacht hat,
weil es im Schwarzen Meer nicht mehr allzu viel abzuschießen gibt mit den Neptuns.
Deswegen haben sie die auch jetzt gegen Bodenziele einsetzbar gemacht.
Gibt noch einiges, was noch im Asowschen Meer rumfährt. Also ich glaube,
da ist noch ein bisschen was zu holen, aber stimmt schon.
Also es ist bemerkenswert. Das Schwarze Meer ist jetzt übrigens so frei gekämpft
worden von der Ukraine, dass jetzt sogar ein Feriendienst nach Georgien wieder
aufgenommen worden ist.
Das finde ich schon bemerkenswert.
Kurz in die Luft geschaut. Russland setzt ja sehr erfolgreich ihre Landsat-Drohnen ein.
Das sind halt auch solche sogenannte Loitering Munition, also quasi fliegende
Bomben, die rumfliegen und nach irgendwelchen Zielen Ausschau halten und dann
erst zum Einsatz kommen, wenn sie was gefunden haben.
Das ist schon eine der erfolgreicheren Waffensysteme, die die Russen benutzen.
In den letzten Tagen gab es aber vermehrt Videos, wo man gesehen hat,
wie wiederum ukrainische Drohnen diese Lancet-Drohnen aufgespürt haben und in
der Luft zerstört haben.
Ja, ist noch ein bisschen unklar, was damit sich auf sich hat,
aber es macht so ein bisschen den Eindruck, als ob sie da eine spezielle Software
oder Tauglichkeit entwickelt haben für ihre Drohnen, um sozusagen so Anti-Loitering
mäßig unterwegs zu sein.
Also Gebiete abzufliegen und nach anderen Drohnen zu schauen,
um dann die Drohnen in der Luft zu zerstören, bevor sie irgendwas zerstören können.
Das ist schon wieder so ein Next Level Luftkrieg. Das wird auch glaube ich weiter so gehen.
Auch auf der See, also wir haben ja diese, man spricht immer von Sea Baby,
das ist glaube ich so ein bisschen der Begriff, der immer rumgeht,
auch wenn es meines Wissens nur der Name einer einzigen Generation dieser bootsbasierten
Drohnen der Ukraine war.
Aber diese Kategorie, also so kleine Boote, die rumfahren, die selber mit Sprengstoff
besetzt sind und die ja einige große Schiffe der Russen zerstört haben,
Die sind weiterhin unterwegs, da haben die Russen auch richtig Schiss.
Also die Kerchbrücke zum Beispiel, die wird jetzt mittlerweile von Ketten von,
wie heißt das, diese Barges, wie heißt das auf Deutsch?
Diese fliegenden Floating-Plattformen sozusagen, wo man einfach so Zeug drauf lädt.
Also keine richtigen Schiffe, sondern die dann halt so gezogen werden.
Mein Gott, da gehen die Begriffe aus. Wie auch immer, auf jeden Fall versuchen
sie die Brücke gegen diese Drohnen abzusichern, genauso wie sie versuchen ihre
Boote dagegen abzusichern.
Was im Wesentlichen darin besteht, dass sie sie verlegen, weil da ist einfach
nicht mehr viel zu holen.
Und jetzt hat man aber auch gesehen, dass die Ukraine mittlerweile welche mit
SAM-Systemen, also Surface-to-Air-Missiles ausgestattet haben,
das heißt auf der Drohne obendrauf sind nochmal Luftabwehrkanonen drauf oder so zwei Missiles drauf.
Ich habe leider kein Video gesehen,
wo die mal erfolgreich zum Einsatz kamen, aber das ist wohl der Versuch der
Gegentaktik der Russen etwas entgegenzusetzen, die wiederum diese Seababy Drohnen
mit Hubschraubern jagen.
Also es gibt immer wieder so Angriffe von diesen Drohnen auf Wasser und die
Russen schicken dann vor allem Hubschrauber in den Kampf gegen die Dinger,
weil die halt die entsprechende Mobilität haben und ausreichend bewaffnet sind
und meine Vermutung ist,
dass sie eben jetzt diese Drohnen dann wiederum um diese kleinen Raketen zum
Abschuss dieser Hubschrauber ausgestattet haben.
Es gab auch eine Variante, wo sie diese Grut-Rockets draufgepackt haben,
die man normalerweise so auf Trucks sieht.
Was ein bisschen merkwürdig ist, weil die nicht gerade besonders bekannt dafür
sind, besonders zielsicher zu sein.
Ja, das sind ungelenkte Raketen.
Ab. Aber habe ich jetzt noch keine erfolgreiche Maske Maßnahme auf Video anschauen
können. Von daher ist das jetzt nur so ein bisschen von mir vermutet,
dass das so die Strategie ist, aber es gibt auf jeden Fall diese Varianten.
Ja.
Ansonsten ist halt...
Der Hunger nach Luftabwehr nach wie vor sehr groß.
Also Zelensky hat sehr viel politische Aktivität entfaltet, um weitere Patriot-Systeme zu bekommen.
Mit der Aussage, wenn wir sieben weitere Systeme haben, dann können wir die
Ukraine damit sichern. Was ich bemerkenswert finde, dass für dieses Riesenland
sieben weitere Systeme, vielleicht insgesamt zehn, ausreichen würden.
Und soweit ich das richtig mitgezählt habe, gibt es derzeit Zusagen für vier Systeme ungefähr.
Deutschland hat nochmal eins geliefert, Rumänien will jetzt eins liefern,
USA vielleicht auch, ich weiß es nicht so ganz genau.
Also das kommt und dann halt noch so diverse,
aus Italien noch so ein Samtee-System,
Nassams soll noch geliefert werden, die Deutschen liefern noch Aristie-Systeme
und dann kommt sogar noch dieses neue Skyranger-System von Rheinmetall,
auf jeden Fall aus Deutschland.
Was so ein Kurzstrecken-Luftabwehrsystem ist, ähnlich wie der Gepard-Panzer,
aber sozusagen als separates System,
was sie dann oben auf alte Chassis von Leopard 1-Panzern draufbauen.
Also ich habe so den Eindruck, dass die Ukraine mittlerweile mit ihrer Argumentation,
wenn wir hier keine ordentliche Luftabwehr haben, dann können wir es auch gleich ganz lassen,
so weit durchgedrungen ist, dass sich hier auch alle nochmal ordentlich am Bein
gezogen haben und dass jetzt also wieder ein verstärkter Flow von Luftabwehrsystemen stattfindet.
Ich meine, nach der ganzen Nummer mit Israel und dem Iran stand das Argument
des Westens auch wirklich auf sehr wackeligen Füßen.
Also da hat man mal eben so 200 Raketen aus dem Iran nahezu zu 99,9 Prozent vernichtet bekommen.
Und in der Ukraine schlagen täglich die Raketen ein. Das war einfach nicht mehr zu vermitteln.
Ja, außerdem noch zusätzliche Heimaßsysteme, hatten wir glaube ich schon erwähnt, 40 weitere kommen,
ist eine Verdoppelung des Bestands, also das wird alles irgendwie hoffentlich
positive Ergebnisse liefern.
Ja, soviel vielleicht zum...
Den ganzen Komplex der Waffensysteme und was sich dort tut.
Jetzt sollten wir nochmal auf ein paar politische Vorgänge eingehen.
Es gab dann die Diskussion über NATO-Soldaten in der Ukraine.
Frankreich hatte dort ja den Vorstoß gemacht, um Ausbilder in die Ukraine zu
setzen und dann auch üblichen Kandidaten, baltische Länder und Polen können sich das vorstellen.
Ich meine, tatsächlich kann man davon ausgehen, dass das eigentlich schon längst
der Fall ist, eigentlich vermutlich schon seit Tag 1.
Eins, der Unterschied ist nur, dass man bisher nur entweder Spezialkräfte senden konnte.
Die sowieso klandestin arbeiten oder dann private Sicherheitsfirmen,
aber eben nicht offiziell Soldaten.
Und sagen, das wäre so ein bisschen der Unterschied, dass dann die Länder quasi
mehr Auswahl haben und die Soldaten
dann auch Mitglieder des französischen Militärs weiterhin bleiben.
Und tatsächlich dann französische Soldaten sind auch nach offiziellem Status
oder dann eben aus den anderen Ländern auch.
Aber es geht nicht darum, jetzt irgendwie komplette Kampfbataillone zu schicken.
Ja, wobei diese Diskussion sich schon auch in der Hinsicht etwas aufheizt.
Also was so Ausbildung betrifft, sind die baltischen Länder ja ohnehin dafür.
Nicht, dass sie das schon tun würden, aber da haben sie gesagt,
da haben sie überhaupt kein Problem mit und ich glaube, das werden wir dann bald auch sehen. gehen.
Für mich klang das schon so konkret, dass das mehr oder weniger alles in Vorbereitung
ist und es wird natürlich dann die Ausbildung in gewisser Hinsicht leichter
machen, weil man eben die ganzen Ukrainer nicht erst woanders hinschicken muss. Ähm,
Ich denke aber, in der Rhetorik war schon mehr herauszulesen.
Also die baltischen Länder haben zum Ausdruck gebracht, dass wenn halt jetzt
die Situation sich in, und ich glaube Polen war es auch schon so ähnlich,
wenn sich die Situation so verschlechtern würde,
dass die Russen nennenswerte Fortschritte machen,
was sie deshalb immerhin nicht tun, aber wenn sie es tun würden,
Dann würde Polen halt auch lieber erstmal die Russen in der Ukraine bekämpfen,
bevor sie jetzt erstmal warten, bis es dann noch wirklich einen Angriff auf Polen gibt.
Ja, interessant ist, dass darüber jetzt, sagen wir, offiziell geredet wird,
weil ich erinnere mich, dass wir ganz am Anfang, so in den ersten Monaten in
der Sendung eben erwähnt hatten, okay, was passiert denn jetzt,
wenn jetzt diese Russen die Ukraine überrennen und Flüchtlingsströme kommen
und eine humanitäre Katastrophe eintritt,
dann bleibt der NATO tatsächlich nichts anderes übrig,
als dort in der Ukraine auch zu intervenieren.
Und zum Beispiel dann, weiß ich
nicht, in der No-Fly-Zone gab es ja diese Diskussion einzurichten und so.
Und insofern wird jetzt das Ganze eben eigentlich nochmal thematisiert,
ist aber aus meiner Sicht jetzt nichts grundlegend Neues.
Aber dass darüber geredet wird, jetzt offen nochmal, ist auf jeden Fall insofern,
bemerkenswert.
Und auch die sonstigen Parameter ändern sich langsam.
Also dieses, ja, Russland auf russischem Territorium angreifen geht gar nicht.
Da sind wir jetzt halt auch drüber hinweg.
Von daher wird noch ein langer Weg sein, bis man wirklich sagt,
so jetzt machen wir hier mal No-Fly-Zone.
Aber es sind auf jeden Fall ein paar der Hinderungsgründe schon weggefallen.
Ja, aber das hat Also Russlands Grenzen lösen sich auch so ein bisschen auf,
beziehungsweise es hat sich Putin ja auch selber eingebrockt,
indem er jetzt Teile der Ukraine zum russischen Staatsgebiet erklärt hat,
hat Russland jetzt keine klar definierten Grenzen mehr.
Und auch mit der Rhetorik, dass er quasi den Zerfall der Sowjetunion als illegal
betrachtet und gerne zurückschrauben möchte,
heißt, dass eben die Frage, was ist Russland eigentlich, wo fängt Russland an
und wo hört Russland auf, zunehmend diffus geworden ist.
Und das hat es natürlich auch ein bisschen vereinfacht, jetzt Russland proper anzugreifen,
beziehungsweise war es ja eh so, dass man ja längst schon aus eigentlich nach
russischer Logik sowieso schon mit der Krim russisches Staatsgebiet schon seit
langem angegriffen hat.
Also diese Schizophrenie tritt jetzt auch zu Tage und jetzt zeigt sich halt,
dass das vielleicht nicht die allerbeste ist.
Idee war strategisch sich ja Teile der Ukraine einzuverleiben.
Wie der ganze Krieg eigentlich keine strategisch besonders kluge Idee war,
das war davon ganz abgesehen.
Also das hatten wir ja auch. Eigentlich hätte er nach einer Woche Kehrt machen
müssen und sagen, okay, war nicht so gemeint.
Und ja, das wäre das Beste gewesen, als klar war, dass die Pläne,
ich meine, es hätte auch gut gehen können.
Ich meine, hatten wir ja oft die Debatte, dass im Westen oder dass eigentlich
alle geglaubt haben, Russland würde das Land überrennen.
Außer uns natürlich. Klar.
Ja, kann man nachhören.
Wir sind ja auch Experten.
Oh Mann, das wird aber irgendwann nochmal ganz interessant werden, unsere Einschätzung.
Ich habe schon überlegt, irgendwann vielleicht mal,
die Transkripte durch eine KI laufen zu lassen und irgendwie mal zusammenzufassen,
was wir denn so alles gesagt haben, zu welchem Zeitpunkt und was sich dann tatsächlich eingetreten ist.
Weil die 50 Stunden mir das alles von Hand anzuhören, weiß ich nicht, ob ich das...
Halluziniere über unsere Erinnerungen. Na gut, mal schauen.
Okay, weiter im Text. Es gab Es gab eine Friedenskonferenz in der Schweiz.
Die hat die Ukraine über einen längeren Zeitraum vorbereitet.
Plan war, möglichst viele Länder der Welt daran teilhaben zu lassen.
Es klang immer wieder mal so durch. Man würde ja gerne sehen,
dass es weit über 100 Teilnehmer werden.
So viele wurden es dann am Ende nicht. Ich glaube, die Zahl lag so bei 90.
Und wenig überraschend, also Russland war ja nun ohnehin nicht eingeladen, aber auch China.
Hat nicht daran teilgenommen, wie auch einige andere halbverbündete Länder Russlands,
da sind also vor allem diese BRICS-Staaten zu nennen, die sich halt extrem zurückhalten,
was ich mal deute als Ergebnis eines Erpressungssystems der Russen.
Also Indien, Brasilien, Südafrika profitieren jetzt sozusagen davon,
dass sie das Maul halten, indem sie halt günstige Energielieferungen bekommen,
die sie gut gebrauchen können, wenn sie halt noch eine Wirtschaft haben,
wie nahezu jede Wirtschaft natürlich, sehr von den Lieferungen fossiler Energien abhängen.
Dann ist das natürlich ein Argument, dazu muss man auch sagen,
dass halt im Süden der Welt die russische Propaganda auch noch sehr viel mehr verfängt als im Westen.
Naja, auf jeden Fall kamen aber dann trotzdem 90 Länder zusammen,
teilweise nicht unbedingt immer mit den höchstmöglichen Vertretern,
also auch die USA hatten jetzt nur, ich weiß nicht, war es Blinken oder war es die Kamala Harris,
ich glaube es war die Kamala Harris, die Vizepräsidentin, also beiden waren natürlich nicht da.
Das hätte mich auch wirklich jetzt sehr gewundert. Wie viel da jetzt bei rausgekommen
ist, ist für mich ein bisschen schwer zu bewerten.
Es gab halt schöne Bilder und es gab sicherlich auch eine Menge Gespräche und
allgemeine Unterstützung und 90 Länder ist ja jetzt auch nicht nichts.
Nichts. Also man hat schon gezeigt, dass ein Großteil der Weltgemeinschaft hinter
der Ukraine steht und das war, glaube ich, ein Wert an sich.
Ja und was vielleicht noch zu erwähnen ist, dass während Südamerika sich bisher
so ein bisschen allgemein rausgehalten hat und weil du auch Brasilien erwähnt hast,
ist jetzt Argentinien im Juni Teil der Ukraine-Unterstützergruppe geworden.
Also Argentinien ist jetzt mit im Boot als erstes südamerikanisches Land,
was jetzt offen die Ukraine unterstützt.
Ja, das ist ja quasi dieser Vogel Millais, den glaube ich keiner derzeit so
richtig einschätzen kann, was mit dem jetzt eigentlich ist.
Der macht ja auch so eine komplett neue Mischung aus crazy und reaktionär auf,
die wir so glaube ich in der Form auch noch nicht haben.
Das ist jetzt quasi die erste Staatsrevolution durch die Libertären.
Da wird man jetzt mal sehen, was das so bringt.
Die Proteste sind ja auch entsprechend angeschwollen in Argentinien,
weil natürlich die ganzen Sparmaßnahmen die Ärmsten natürlich mal wieder am
härtesten treffen. Aber das ist jetzt ein ganz anderes Thema.
Ich will nur sagen, Argentinien agiert hier, mir ist nicht ganz klar,
was die Perspektive von Millet auf die Welt ist und was so seine Vorstellung
von internationalen Allianzen ist.
Andererseits hätte man aber jetzt von so einem Kraftmeier, der ja irgendwie
ist, intuitiv glaube ich erstmal was anderes erwartet.
Aber ähnlich wie auch Meloni in Italien und so weiter sind die Allianzen gar
nicht so einfach zu zeichnen immer.
Ja, es sind Populisten und wenn die sehen einfach, okay, sie sind alle dann
nicht so wirklich ideologisch.
Die sind vielleicht ein bisschen irgendwie verrückt, aber ja,
haben keine feste Ideologie.
Hat man auch schon mal öfter diskutiert. Wie die Nazis auch,
die dann so die Japaner zu Ehrenariern erklärt haben.
Ja, das ist dieselbe Kategorie. Ich sag mal Flexibilität, wenn es denn irgendwie
nützt. Das ist halt was Populisten machen.
Ja, Putin hat aber dann passend zur Konferenz vorher noch ein Waffenstillstandsangebot
einen Tag vorher rausgehauen, um erstmal die ganzen Debatten wieder zu hijacken.
Da hat sich dann natürlich, bin ich überrascht, keiner so richtig drauf eingelassen.
Ja, es ist einfach absurd irgendwie.
Beanspruchten Territorien der Ukraine zurückzieht. Und außerdem auf einen NATO-Beitritt
verzichtet und der Westen alle Sanktionen aufhebt.
So, dann ist er zu einem Waffenstillstand bereit.
Ja, also das ist offensichtlich nicht ernst zu nehmen.
Das ist Getrolle auf hohem Niveau und sollte einfach eben dieser Friedenskonferenz
Zeit und Aufmerksamkeit stehlen.
Was auch gelungen ist, leider zu einem Teil.
Ja, weil da muss ja dann unbedingt darüber berichtet werden,
über diesen Quatsch. auch wenn man das vorher hätte schon erwarten können.
Aber so funktioniert nun mal der Medienzirkus.
Ja, ist aber dann interessanterweise doch keiner drauf eingegangen. Wer hätte es gedacht?
Ja, ansonsten ist glaube ich nicht so richtig viel Kurzfristiges zu vermelden,
was diese Konferenz betrifft.
Aber es ist schon mal gut, dass sie stattgefunden hat und es soll auch noch
in diesem Jahr eine zweite Iteration davon geben.
Ja, also man kann auf jeden Fall aus der Konferenz entnehmen,
dass ungefähr 90 Länder, also wenn man das jetzt an der Zahl der Länder abliest,
ist es ungefähr die Hälfte, größenordnungsmäßig,
haben daran teilgenommen.
Und ja, die andere Hälfte halt nicht. Aber da sind natürlich dann viele Länder
dabei, die auch gar nicht die Kapazität haben Oder die einfach so weit ab vom Schuss sind,
dass das für die keinen Sinn macht, teilzunehmen.
Schauen wir mal nach Russland und die wirtschaftliche Entwicklung.
Da gibt es ja sehr widersprüchliche Berichte schon seit Wochen und Monaten.
Also je nachdem, wo man hinhört, hört man eigentlich alles von das Land steht
kurz vor dem Kollaps bis hin zu die russische Wirtschaft boomt.
Und ich glaube, die Wahrheit ist, das stimmt alles so ein bisschen auf seine
Art und Weise, aber die Belastungen sind für Russland hoch.
Und dieser Wirtschaftsboom, der tatsächlich auf dem Papier da ist,
besteht im Kern aus dem Staat, der halt sehr viel Geld in die Militärindustrie
reinpumpt, was dann zu Beschäftigung, Aufträgen und so weiter führt.
Das heißt klar, das ist dann eine staatliche Investitionsmaßnahme.
Hätte man auch in was anderes investieren können, aber jetzt ist es halt der
Militärkomplex und das führt natürlich dann zu einer entsprechenden Umpolung
der Wirtschaft, die sich darauf einlässt, weil dort dann Kohle zu holen ist
und Personal gebraucht wird.
Aber auf der anderen Seite ist dieses Geld in dem Sinne ja gar nicht da,
weil Russland halt auf einer Seite seine ganzen Auslandsdevisen sind beschlagnahmt worden,
die Einnahmen aus Öl und Gas, die halt den Großteil der Staatseinnahmen gemacht haben, sinken.
Also es fiel auf Pump. Und das führt jetzt auch dazu, dass halt auf der einen
Seite die Inflationsrate steigt, Produkte sehr viel teurer werden,
Kartoffeln auf einmal 50 Prozent mehr kosten binnen eines Jahres,
was für Russen ein großes Problem ist.
Und ähnlich hatten wir, glaube ich, auch schon mal Zuckerkrise und andere Bereiche
im Lebensmittelsegment, die halt teurer geworden sind.
Die Inflationsrate steigt und jetzt sind halt auch Steuererhöhungen angekündigt worden.
Interessanterweise aber eher für die Wohlhabenderen in Russland.
Da hat er vielleicht gemerkt, dass dann bei den Armen vielleicht doch nicht
so viel zu holen ist oder die Maßnahme so unpopulär wäre, dass er sie nicht machen kann.
Da bin ich dann mal gespannt, wie der russische Mittelstand darauf reagiert,
wenn dann auf einmal der Zar dann tatsächlich Kohle von den Reichen haben will.
Ja, also was wohl, so wie ich das verstanden habe,
passiert ist, also sie haben jetzt nicht einfach die Druckerpresse angeworfen,
sondern sie haben in dem Sinne echtes Geld in die Wirtschaft gepumpt.
Aber das hat dann eben zu einer Überhitzung der Wirtschaft geführt,
weil plötzlich ist halt mehr Geld da Und das hat dann eben die Preise nach oben
getrieben, weil das Warenangebot dann nicht in entsprechender Menge da war,
beziehungsweise dann einfach Raum für Preiserhöhungen auf einmal da war.
Und gerade halt teilweise auch die extrem hohen Soldatengehälter,
die ja plus eben die relativ hohe Gehälter im militärisch-industriellen Komplex,
so das hat dann eben zu einer Überhitzung geführt.
Und um jetzt Inflation zu bekämpfen,
hatte man ja auch wie überall auf der Welt, wie das auch die USA und Europa
gemacht hatten nach Kriegseinbruch, als überall die Inflation nach oben ging,
hat man dann eben auch die Basiszinsen erhöht, so von der Zentralbank aus,
um damit die Inflation zu bekämpfen. Impfen.
Im Westen hat das auch geklappt. Also bei uns ist die Inflationsrate und auch
in den USA danach gesunken und.
Russland so hatte noch vor den Wahlen angekündigt, dass auch die Inflationsrate im Griff ist.
Nach den Wahlen hat aber die Zentralbank plötzlich erzählt, wir müssen aber
die Zinsen weiter hochhalten, weil die Inflationsrate ist immer noch nicht gesunken
und wir erwarten jetzt auch nicht, dass sie in naher Zukunft sinkt.
Das heißt, wir sind so ein bisschen jetzt eben auch in der Zinsinflationsfalle drin.
Und dann wurden halt jetzt auch noch verschiedene Maßnahmen,
also durch die Sanktionen, die jetzt ausgeweitet wurden,
die haben jetzt weiter die Friktion im System erhöht.
Also die Sanktionen konnten ganz gut umgangen werden an vielen Stellen,
aber das treibt natürlich die Preise in die Höhe, weil du machst halt Schmuggler
und eben Firmen in anderen Ländern und so.
Das heißt, das macht halt einfach mehr Aufwand und das kostet Geld und verteuert damit die Waren.
Und jetzt wurde eben nochmal einer draufgesetzt,
weil es wurde eine neue Sanktionsliste von den USA herausgegeben,
wo dann wieder jetzt 400 Firmen und Individuen mit Sanktionen belegt wurden
und unter anderem die Devisenbörse in Russland.
Und die war daraufhin gezwungen, ihren Handel mit Dollar und Euro einzustellen.
Was halt bedeutet, dass es jetzt keinen offiziellen Börsenkurs mehr in Russland gibt.
Gut, abgesehen davon, dass der ohnehin massiv beeinflusst war durch eben wiederum
Zentralbankinterventionen, Dann ist es aber jetzt so,
dass Dollar und Euro in Russland jetzt nur noch over the counter gehandelt werden, OTC,
von jeder Bank einzeln.
Das heißt, jede Bank kann jetzt ihre eigenen Wechselkurse machen.
Und am Anfang war es so, dass dort, weil niemand wusste, was jetzt der Dollar eigentlich wert ist,
wenn du tauschen wolltest, einige Banken einen Spread von vier hatten.
Das heißt, dass du...
Wenn du 100, war das, genau,
1 Dollar kaufen wolltest, du 200 Rubel bezahlen musstest, aber wenn du 1 Dollar
verkauft hast, du nur 50 bekommen hast dafür.
Also einmal hin und zurück tauschen und du hast nur noch ein Viertel deines Geldes.
Du hast nur noch ein Viertel, genau. Und das macht es natürlich jetzt deutlich schwieriger,
auch wieder die Sanktionen zu umgehen und in bestimmten Ländern einzukaufen.
Und das trifft vor allem die Russen, die so ihre Reserven ohnehin in diesen
harten Währungen angelegt haben.
Also wenn du zu Geld gekommen bist, dann in Russland, dann hast du das nicht
alles als Rubel unter der Matratze liegen,
sondern selbstverständlich ist sehr viel davon in Dollar und Euro angelegt,
weil das halt stabile Währungen sind, mit denen du im Zweifelsfall halt auch
direkt eins zu eins die Dinge kaufen kannst,
die du gerne haben möchtest, wenn du ein bisschen mehr Geld auszugeben hast, Autos und so weiter.
Da die ganze Importware gibt es halt dann auch nicht so ohne weiteres in Rubel,
beziehungsweise kaufst es halt sowieso im Ausland und das ist natürlich jetzt
sehr schwierig geworden,
diese Reserven dann wiederum in Rubel umzusetzen, wenn du halt mal Rubel brauchst,
weil du halt ja auch dort was ausgeben musst.
Ja, ich glaube, es war sogar so, dass auf einigen russischen Gebrauchtwagenbörsen
die Preise in Dollar oder in Euro ausgezeichnet waren.
Weil man einfach zu viel Konfusion da war und das mit dem Rubel zu schnell rauf
und runter gegangen ist und man so auch dann mit Dollar und Euro einfach besser
für Autonachschub sorgen konnte.
Ja, das heißt, der Handel und die Sanktionsumgehung mit dem Westen ist halt schwieriger geworden.
Und ein zum wichtigsten Handelspartner von Russland ist halt dann jetzt China geworden, definitiv.
Und auch eben, ja, sehr wichtig,
aber China zieht halt nur so halb mit, beziehungsweise wenn es dann um chinesische Interessen geht,
so ist China China wichtiger.
Und dann müssen die Russen halt,
also soweit geht die, wie sie das vor dem Krieg angekündigt hatten,
soweit geht die uneingeschränkte Freundschaft dann doch nicht.
Er hat halt doch gewisse Grenzen.
Und in der Sanktionsliste waren dann eben auch Niederlassungen russischer Banken in China,
die dann auch direkt sanktioniert wurden.
Wurden, die bisher der Sanktionsumgehung auch dienten oder den Handel zwischen
Russland und Amerika erleichtert haben.
Und mittlerweile haben natürlich Russland und China auch irgendwie einen Weg drumherum gefunden.
Also irgendwie gibt es immer einen Weg drumherum, aber der ist halt auch wieder etwas komplizierter.
Und wenn jetzt sie Finanzverkehr machen wollen, können russische Unternehmen
eben entweder so ein Non-Resident-Konto bei einer chinesischen Bank eröffnen,
also im Prinzip ja ein Auslandskonto eröffnen oder eine chinesische Tochtergesellschaft
gründen und dann ein Konto im Inland eröffnen und mit dem dann Geschäft machen.
Aber das macht alles natürlich auch nicht unbedingt leicht.
Aber erstens können sie jetzt nicht mehr bei der russischen Bank ein Konto eröffnen,
sondern müssen jetzt zu einer chinesischen Bank gehen oder eine Tochtergesellschaft gründen.
Ja, und das hat vermutlich dann auch dazu geführt, jetzt, das hattest du erwähnt,
glaube ich, dass jetzt unter anderem Alibaba keine Rubel mehr annimmt.
Kannst du da noch was vor sagen?
Ja, also ich meine, ich bin mir jetzt gerade nicht ganz so sicher,
ob die jetzt schon ausgesprochen wurden oder ob das nur noch eine Drohung ist,
aber es drohen jetzt halt Sekundärsanktionen.
Also die USA gehen jetzt in zunehmendem Maße dahin über, die Sanktionen in die
Richtung zu verschärfen. Wenn ihr mit Russland in irgendeiner Form Handel treibt,
dann sanktionieren wir euch im Westen.
Und das hat eben jetzt dazu geführt, dass Alibaba keine Rubelbezahlung mehr
annimmt und auch nicht mehr nach Russland liefert.
Ich weiß nicht, wie viele andere Online-Trader das jetzt auch noch betrifft,
aber das ist natürlich auf jeden Fall schon mal hart,
weil Alibaba ist einfach mal fett, ist richtig, richtig groß und das betrifft wohl primär Banken.
Also die Kette geht also hier tatsächlich entlang der Banken,
sprich eine chinesische Bank,
die jetzt mit Russland da entsprechende finanzielle Transaktionen macht,
die werden dann halt von den USA mit Sanktionen belegt, sodass die dann wiederum
mit dem Westen keinen Handel mehr treiben können und dann überlegen die sich halt schon,
ob sie lieber mit den USA Geld verdienen wollen oder mit Russland,
weil Russland ist jetzt halt auch so viel nicht zu holen.
Äh...
Das ist sozusagen das Problem.
Wusstest du eigentlich, was die gesetzliche Grundlage dafür ist,
dass die USA diese Sanktionen ausspricht, also in den USA?
Das ist der sogenannte CAATSA-Act, der von Donald Trump ins Gesetz gezeichnet wurde,
obwohl er dann das auch kritisiert hat, meinte es sei seriously flawed,
aber er wurde mit einer großen Mehrheit in Haus und Senat verabschiedet.
Und heißt halt eben Countering America's Adversaries Through Sanctions Act.
Also Amerikas Feinden mit Sanktionen entgegenwirken Gesetz, wenn man so will.
Und das gibt den Amerikanern eigentlich extreme Freiheiten, dabei Unternehmen zu sanktionieren.
Also vorher mussten Sanktionen dann auch durchs Parlament und das ist dann auch
ein gewisses Ermächtigungsgesetz,
was die Sanktionierung vereinfacht.
Und den gibt es seit 2017.
Und der wurde meines Wissens dann auch als erstes gegen verschiedene Firmen angewandt,
die mit Nord Stream involviert waren.
Was dazu führte, dass sich dann verschiedene Firmen aus Nord Stream zurückgezogen haben.
Also auch deutsche Firmen wurden und werden unter diesem Gesetz sanktioniert,
wenn sie Dinge machen, die den USA nicht passen.
Ja, also insgesamt habe ich so den Eindruck, also die Vorstellung,
dass es wirklich eine chinesisch-russische Freundschaft gibt,
ich glaube von der kann man sich gleich mal trennen.
China kann Russland nicht leiden, das ist nur ein, der Feind meines Feindes
ist mein Freund Effekt, solange ihnen das halt passt, aber Russland hat auch
den Chinesen Land weggenommen und die haben auch sehr viel,
Konflikte und China versucht jetzt einfach aus der Situation das Beste für sich
rauszuholen, was irgendwie geht aber sie sind jetzt auch nicht bereit für Russland zu sterben,
deren ist Russland an der Stelle egal,
solange Russland als Machtzentrum international noch erhalten bleibt.
Also China wäre es nicht recht, wenn Russland komplett untergeht,
aber hat jetzt auch nicht unbedingt was einzuwenden, wenn Russland geschwächt
wird insofern, als dass es dann eben China stärkt.
Und eine Sache, die jetzt gerade letzte Woche aufkam,
die das vielleicht ganz schön unterstreicht ist, dass es jetzt ein Abkommen
gibt zwischen Russland und China und ich bin mir gar nicht so sicher,
inwiefern jetzt auch Nordkorea da noch mit hat zustimmen müssen. Ich vermute mal ja.
Und zwar der Zugang zum Tumen-Fluss. Hast du das mitbekommen?
Ja, das ist nämlich die Grenze zwischen Nordkorea und Russland am japanischen
Meer und also das sozusagen das im Osten gelegene Meer,
also im Osten Japans gelegene Meer und tatsächlich grenzen nur Russland im Norden
und Nord- und Südkorea im Süden an dieses Meer.
Allerdings gibt es so einen kleinen chinesischen Zipfel, der ungefähr 25 Kilometer
oder so bis an diese Mündung des Tumenflusses kommt.
Also dieser Fluss ist die Grenze zwischen China und Nordkorea,
bis er dann eben nur noch die Grenze zwischen Russland und Nordkorea ist auf
diesen letzten Metern bis zum japanischen Meer.
Und ja, das war sozusagen für China ein nicht erreichbarer Zugang zum japanischen Meer.
Und da gab es jetzt wohl eine Einigung.
Dass China künftig diesen Fluss nutzen kann, um zu dem Meer zu kommen.
Und wenn man sich das mal auf der Weltkarte anschaut, bisher hatte China halt
nur Zugang zum Gelben Meer, also alles was westlich von Nordkorea und Südkorea
liegt und keinen direkten Zugang zum japanischen Meer.
Und das würde sich dadurch halt ändern und das macht natürlich einen riesen
Unterschied, weil man dann zum Beispiel Handelsrouten direkt nach Japan leichter machen kann.
Ich weiß nicht wie viel Trade es gibt zwischen Japan und China,
aber es wird sicherlich was sein.
Aber es hat natürlich auch eine
militärische Dimension, wo Japan jetzt vielleicht nicht so amused ist,
dass potenziell China hier direkten Zugang zum japanischen Meer erhält,
wo schon im sonstigen pazifischen Raum Chinas Militärpräsenz ein Problem darstellt.
Ja, also es gibt allerdings auch gewisse Zweifel, dass das Realität werden wird aus mehreren Gründen.
Erstmal wäre es erforderlich, dass der Fluss ausgebaggert wird,
sodass es kostet erstmal Geld.
Also das muss jemand tun. Okay, China bezahlt bestimmt gerne dafür.
Das wäre wahrscheinlich nicht das Problem, aber er muss halt erstmal ausgebaggert werden.
Ein zweiter Punkt ist, dass Nordkorea gewisse Probleme damit haben könnte,
wenn dort an ihrer Grenze sichtbar für ihre ganze Bevölkerung lauter vollbepackte
Schiffe rauf und runter fahren.
Ja, also dass das halt, ja, gut, das ist vielleicht lösbar, dann stellt man
Zäune auf oder nimmt die Bevölkerung vom Fluss zurück.
Aber das ist nicht so einfach so. Da sind Leute, das ist bevölkert,
die Gegend und das ist sozusagen ein zweiter Aspekt.
Der dritte Aspekt ist, dass China sich ja so ein bisschen auch als Pate von Nordkorea sieht.
Und jetzt aber Russland...
Und ja, Russland dort,
dass Russland jetzt dort in Nordkorea einwirkt, da ist man auch nicht so glücklich drüber.
Das heißt, es könnte eben auch Widerstand dann von russischer Seite geben an der Stelle.
Also sozusagen alle Länder eigentlich haben so, außer China natürlich,
haben so gewisse Probleme damit.
Und deswegen, ja, noch ist es nicht Realität, wenn das vielleicht in einem Jahr
oder wenn es dann passiert,
nochmal wieder aufnehmen müssen,
ob das jetzt nur viel geredet war oder tatsächlich dort was passiert.
Gut, mag sein, zeigt aber die gekommenen Bewegungen, was Russland und China betrifft.
China hat sehr viel Einfluss jetzt auf das Geschehen und Russland hat einen
hohen Unterstützungsbedarf, den sie halt eigentlich nur von China,
Nordkorea, Iran und anderen Schurkenstaaten irgendwie erhalten.
Und das ist halt auch keine besonders, wie soll ich sagen,
keine Allianz der Liebe und gemeinsamen Überzeugung, weil das halt auch alles
Länder sind, die ideologisch eigentlich gar nichts gemeinsam haben,
sondern ihre Gemeinsamkeit besteht
eigentlich nur darin, dass sie alle irgendwie was gegen die USA haben.
Ja, das ist ein guter Punkt, weil da hat sich allerdings einiges verändert.
Und zwar habe ich von einer Anekdote gehört, dass damals in der 2007,
2008er Finanzkrise Putin an China herangetreten sein soll.
Und China aufgefordert haben, hey,
wollen wir nicht die internationale Finanzordnung jetzt endgültig zum Einsturz
bringen und die Amerikaner sind jetzt ohnehin angeschlagen,
zieht doch eure Kredite an die USA zurück.
Also hat versucht, China zu überreden, die USA in den Bankrott zu treiben.
Und damals, das war halt auch noch vor Xi, haben die Chinesen gesagt, bist du irre?
Weil hast du sie nicht alle? Weil das ist unser größter Handelspartner und,
Und seit Bretton Woods, so ist das unser militärischer Garant,
der unsere Schiffe auf allen Weltmeeren beschützt.
Und wir haben gar nicht die militärische Fähigkeit, unseren Handel weltweit zu schützen.
Das müssen die Amerikaner für uns tun.
Und ja, das war wie gesagt 2007, 2008.
Jetzt ist es so, dass sich China so ein bisschen zugänglicher zeigt für Überlegungen,
die USA zumindest zu schwächen.
So, weil erstens, ich meine, hat man jetzt deswegen auch das Militär ausgebaut,
um eben den eigenen Außenhandel auch zu schützen, weil man eben völlig abhängig
ist von der USA und ihrem Militär gegenwärtig.
Und ja, auf der anderen Seite ist China jetzt eine Entwicklung durchgemacht
und ist jetzt ein bisschen offener.
Aber von dem Ausgangspunkt seid ihr irre oder bist du irre geworden.
Und es wird wohl wahrscheinlich eher noch,
keine Ahnung, wenn alles gut geht für China, was auch nicht aussieht,
fünf bis zehn Jahre dauern, bevor China überhaupt realistisch in der Lage wäre,
jetzt die USA wirklich herauszufordern.
Und ja, es macht im Moment null Sinn für China, sagen jetzt den USA oder dem
Westen schweren Schaden zuzufügen.
Ja. So, aber Putin versucht ja auch seine Verbindung zu Nordkorea zu halten
und ist jetzt nach 24 Jahren das erste Mal wieder in Nordkorea selbst aufgelaufen und damit glaube ich,
wenn ich es richtig sehe, das erste Mal auch als Präsident Russlands.
Also das letzte Mal, als er da war, war er das noch nicht. Oder wie lange ist
er jetzt? Er ist seit 20 Jahren an der Macht oder 16.
Ja und was für eine Show das war.
Man kann sich das ja in etwa vorstellen, wie das so in Nordkorea so läuft.
Da hast du dann erstmal tausend kreischende Kinder mit Wink-Elementen,
die irgendwie alles befeiern und die ganze Zeit musst du ja mit Kim Jong-un
da irgendwo rumpräsentieren und rumlaufen und sich besingen lassen.
Das war schon alles sehr cringe.
Tausende Jubel-Koreaner. Und überall die ganze Stadt, ja alles voll von Porträts mit Putin und Kim.
Und lustig war aber, dass die beiden gleich groß aussahen.
Und ich glaube aber nicht, dass die beiden gleich groß sind.
Das heißt, es gibt jetzt Vermutungen, dass vorher man diplomatisch sozusagen
ausgehandelt hat, wie hoch Plateauschuhe jeder anzuziehen hat,
damit beide gleich groß erscheinen.
Okay, mal so ganz nebenbei, wichtiger weltpolitischer Aspekt, Schuheinlagen.
Genau.
Aber eigentlich war es ja eine Erniedrigung für Putin. Also sich wirklich mit
so einem Land wie Nordkorea auf Augenhöhe da abzugeben und so einen Staatsbesuch zu machen,
ist ja quasi für Kim Jong-un der höchstmögliche Score, den er so bekommen kann.
Abgesehen vielleicht Trump noch irgendwie einzuladen oder so. Ja.
Ja, das ist sicherlich eigentlich eine Demütigung für Putin,
dass er dazu genötigt ist, das zu tun.
Weil die Zahl derer, die bereit sind, auch ihre Industrieproduktion in den Dienst
des Ukraine-Krieges zu stellen, ist begrenzt.
Die ist eng begrenzt. Ja, es ist Weißrussland und jetzt Nordkorea, weiß nicht, und Iran.
Mehr fällt mir gerade nicht ein, wer Russland irgendwie sonst noch Waffen liefert
oder bei der Waffenherstellung hilft.
Das ist auf jeden Fall ein hoher Preis, den er dafür zahlen muss.
Ja, und es könnte aber unterm Strich ein erheblicher strategischer Fehler sein.
Wir hatten das auch schon mal irgendwann vor N Sendungen erwähnt,
dass natürlich Südkorea sehr aufmerksam beobachtet,
was dort Russland an Nordkorea liefert, insbesondere an Technologie.
Und Südkorea hat sich bisher mit der Unterstützung der Ukraine zurückgehalten,
ist zwar mit im Boot und hat Granaten an NATO-Länder geliefert beispielsweise,
die dann dadurch in der Lage waren,
aus eigenen Beständen an die Ukraine zu liefern.
Ringtausch. Ja, Ringtausch, wenn du so willst.
Und hat außerdem eben nicht-militärische Hilfsgüter geliefert in größerem Umfang.
Und Polen hat dort ja größere Mengen an Waffen eingekauft,
weil Südkorea mittlerweile auch, die haben eine erhebliche auch Schwerindustrie
und auch eine sehr potente Waffenindustrie,
weil die halt seit ihrer Existenz im Krieg sich befinden.
Weil es gibt ja keinen Friedensvertrag mit Nordkorea.
Die befinden sich ja seit 50 Jahren im Waffenstillstand oder 60 Jahren.
Das heißt, deswegen hat Südkorea natürlich auch entsprechende Kapazitäten und
Reserven angelegt an Waffen und hat eben mittlerweile auch,
ja, produziert moderne Waffen mit hohem Standard und exportiert auch zunehmend mehr.
Und es wird davon ausgegangen.
Auch im Auge behalten, aber dass eben aufgrund dieses Treffens Putin mit Kim
und den zugesagten Technologieunterstützungen,
dass Südkorea dazu bewegen wird,
ihre Position zu überdenken und auch Direktwaffen an die Ukraine zu liefern.
Und das wäre also sicherlich auch nochmal dann am Ende ein strategischer Fehlschlag,
beziehungsweise würde das dazu führen,
dass letztlich die Zunahme,
was Russland an nordkoreanischen schlechten Waffen dazu gewinnt,
gewinnt dann die Ukraine an südkoreanischen guten Waffen möglicherweise dazu. zu.
Also,
es abzuwarten, wie sich das entwickelt wird, aber im Moment gehen sehr viele
Leute davon aus, dass das Südkoreas Reaktion sein wird auf das,
was Putin da jetzt veranstaltet hat.
Ja.
Ja, so viel zu Putin in Nordkorea.
Ich glaube, die haben so eine Art Verteidigungspakt irgendwie angekündigt,
aber ich weiß nicht, ob da viel dahinter steht.
Das scheint mir alles nur so ein bisschen tamtam zu sein.
Naja, die andere Sache ist, was auch strategisch nicht so klug ist,
ist dieser Konflikt zwischen Nord- und Südkorea.
Wenn Russland dort einen Beistandstakt eingeht, würde es in einen Konflikt,
der dort ausbricht, auch sofort hineingezogen.
Das heißt, es gibt damit noch quasi dann auch nochmal,
wenn wir das ernst nehmen, ein weiteres Einfallstor oder einen weiteren potenziellen
Destabilisierungsfaktor, den er sich damit eingetreten hat.
Ja, also es ist halt, man sieht,
dass Russland schon Schwierigkeiten hat, seine Allianzen zu finden und ich bin
sehr gespannt, wie Südkorea da reagieren wird. Ja.
Die die vom Westen eingefroren wurde, dass die in irgendeiner Form für den Wiederaufbau
und die Unterstützung der Ukraine zum Einsatz kommen.
Und das war ein ziemliches Hin und Her über einen längeren Zeitraum.
Aber jetzt ist es auch auf dem G7-Treffen beschlossen worden.
Ich weiß nicht, ob diese drei Milliarden drin erhalten sind.
Also die G7 hat insgesamt von 50 Milliarden Dollar, ich glaube pro Jahr,
die quasi aus diesen eingefrorenen Geldern an Zinsen erwirtschaftet werden können,
dass die an die Ukraine gehen sollen.
Lange Zeit stand ja auch zur Debatte, dass irgendwie der eigentliche Betrag
selbst direkt an die Ukraine geht.
Das Problem ist nur, dass...
Eine Maßnahme wäre, die folgenschwere Implikationen haben könnte für den Westen
als Finanzstandort für die Welt.
Weil wenn jetzt sozusagen alle befürchten müssen, dass ihnen einfach die Kohle
weggenommen wird, das ist so nicht gut.
Weil da gibt es ja auch Verträge, die dann gebrochen würden etc.
Bei den Zinsen sind sie jetzt quasi in Kompromiss eingegangen.
Ich habe keine Ahnung von internationaler Wirtschaftspolitik an der Stelle und
was da für Verträge greifen und wie das rechtlich alles so aussieht,
aber offensichtlich haben sie sich zumindest dazu durchgerungen,
hier der Ukraine damit so einen konstanten Moneyflow zu organisieren.
Ja, ich meine, es ist ja auch so, dass man sozusagen dass der Westen ja für eine,
Herrschaft des Gesetzes eintritt. Und das ist natürlich dann umso weniger überzeugend,
je mehr man einfach seine eigenen Gesetze dann so umbiegt,
wie sie einem denn passen, also sich quasi einfach aufs russische Niveau hinabbegibt.
So ja auf der anderen seite ist es wahrscheinlich nur eine frage der zeit.
Bis man dann sagt, ja, wir nehmen jetzt auch einfach, wir kassieren jetzt auch
einfach den Rest ein, weil, aber das kann halt lange dauern.
Also speziell, wenn man das Ganze dann gerichtlich durchficht,
kann man so von 10 bis 20 Jahren Prozessdauer ausgehen,
wenn das dann auf dem Rechtsweg entschieden wird.
Und man geht davon aus, dass das mit den Zinsen, wie du schon sagst,
als Kompromiss jetzt erstmal durchgehen wird,
wobei ich mit Sicherheit davon ausgehe, dass auch darum Prozesse geführt werden,
dass Russland auch Anspruch auf die Zinsen erheben wird.
Und dass irgendwann auch ein Gericht entscheiden muss, ob das Bestand hat oder nicht.
Ob das verfassungsmäßig war zum Beispiel, was da abgelaufen ist oder gegen andere
Verträge verstößt oder so.
Also das wird man erst in 20 Jahren endgültig sehen, wo am Ende wie viel Geld gelandet ist.
Aber erstmal hilft es natürlich der Ukraine auf jeden Fall, das zu tun und ich heiße das auch gut.
Ja, das bringt uns jetzt erstmal ans Ende unserer Notizen zum Konflikt.
Ihr merkt schon, keine fundamentalen großen Änderungen,
aber insgesamt ein leichter Shift hin zu einer Stabilisierung der Frontlinie,
Stabilisierung der Situation,
einer Verstärkung der ukrainischen Position,
einer Schwächung der russischen Position, aber alles noch ein wenig in Zeitlupe.
Ich habe den Eindruck, generell bewegt sich das jetzt in eine richtige Richtung,
könnte allerdings auch noch deutlich mehr Thermik vertragen.
Was glaube ich so ein bisschen wie ein Damoklesschwert über der Gesamtsituation
schwebt, ist halt natürlich die Wahl in den USA.
Davon wird jetzt sehr viel abhängen. Der Wahlkampf hat jetzt begonnen,
die Aufmerksamkeit der Amerikaner ist, wie fast immer, aber jetzt eben noch
ein bisschen mehr, komplett auf sich selbst.
So internationale Konflikte spielen keine sonderlich große Rolle natürlich,
weil wir ja wissen, wie das so abläuft mit Trump, ist das Ganze halt einfach
eine riesige Shitshow und keiner kann jetzt sagen, wie das so ausgeht.
Und meine Erwartungshaltung ist nach wie vor, dass sich am Ende dann doch Biden
durchsetzen werden kann und ich mag mir auch überhaupt nicht vorstellen,
wie es aussehen würde, sollte tatsächlich Trump nochmal eine Präsidentschaft gewinnen.
Aber man weiß es halt nicht und deswegen ist glaube ich alles auch so ein wenig politisch on hold.
Wenn es halt Biden schafft, diese Wahl zu gewinnen, dann ist das halt auch das
Ende von Trump, weil ich glaube, das wird dann die letzte Wahl sein,
zu der er angetreten sein wird.
Als nächstes ist er dann wahrscheinlich wirklich im Knast, weil dann fehlen
ihm die Mittel und die Unterstützung, weitere Gerichtsverfahren gegen ihn nennenswert
herauszuzögern. Das ist dann schon so sein Ende.
Und ich hoffe, dass das kommen wird. Und das wird dann eben auch die ganze Situation
mit der Ukraine dahingehend ändern, als das natürlich dann Putin jeden Grund
hat, die letzte Hoffnung fahren zu lassen.
Wenn Biden sozusagen die Freiheit hat und das setzt natürlich auch voraus,
dass er auch Senat und Kongress wieder zurückgewinnt.
Also das wäre schon die Konstellation.
Also nicht nur die Präsidentschaft gewinnen, sondern auch wieder die Mehrheit
im Kongress zu bekommen. Das wäre halt wichtig, dass er eben dann entsprechende
Maßnahmen auch beschließen kann.
Sollte das so kommen, dann kann ich mir auch vorstellen, dass die Unterstützung
noch weiter zunehmen wird.
Aber da sind wir jetzt noch nicht und das werden wir dann erst im September wissen.
Ja, aber darf ich noch kurz, obwohl wir eigentlich ja auf einen positiven Ausblick enden wollten,
oder ich mir gewünscht hätte, wir könnten auf einen positiven Ausblick wenden,
aber weil du das Thema Trump jetzt angesprochen hast.
Erst, die erste Trump-Präsidentschaft war sehr dilettantisch.
Trump hat zwar eine Menge Schaden angerichtet, aber es war, ich sag mal, noch begrenzt.
Er hat den Superior Court umgekrempelt und so, aber Mexiko hat nichts für die Mauer bezahlt.
Und auch ansonsten viele Dinge, außer diese Roe vs.
Wade-Abtreibungsrechtsprechung zu kippen, ist da nicht viel umgesetzt worden,
weil es eben auch damit was zu tun hat.
Dass mit jedem Regierungswechsel ist es ein bisschen anders als in Deutschland,
wie der öffentliche Dienst besetzt wird.
Aber grundsätzlich gibt es auch in Deutschland dann beamtete Staatssekretäre
und dann eben ernannte Staatssekretäre, die dann den Minister zuarbeiten.
Und in den USA ist es so, dass auf Bundesebene der Großteil der, ich weiß nicht,
Hunderttausenden von Bundesangestellten sind halt im Prinzip so eine Art Beamte.
Es gibt keinen Beamtenstatus, aber die haben halt ihre Jobs und die sind unabhängig
von der jeweiligen Regierung.
Wenn die Regierung wechselt, ändert sich an deren Beschäftigungsstatus nichts.
Und dann gibt es eben die Appointees, da gehören einen Teil der Botschafter
dazu, Dazu, da gehören dann jeweils die gesamte Spitze des Weißen Hauses dazu,
plus eben dann in den Ministerien Teile der Ministerialbürokratie.
Das sind so ungefähr 3000 Leute.
Und es war wohl so, als Trump dann die Macht übernommen hat, als er gewählt wurde,
so fragte dann wohl Eric oder fragten sie dann, ja, als sie dann im Weißen Haus
waren, ja, wie viel von den Leuten, die hier arbeiten,
bleiben eigentlich,
so und ja, guckt ihn nur an und ja, keiner, ja, sondern ihr müsst euch Leute
suchen, ja, so, das heißt, damit, so ging das los.
Also sie waren mit anderen Worten, Trump war halt komplett unvorbereitet und
auch die Konservativen waren unvorbereitet, weil niemand damit gerechnet hatte,
dass Trump gewinnen würde, auch die Republikaner nicht selber.
Das heißt, sie wussten jetzt nicht wirklich, wie damit umzugehen ist und deswegen
ist das relativ ineffektiv geblieben.
Jetzt ist es so, dass sich...
Jede Menge konservativer Unterstützergruppen und
Super-PACs und religiöse Gruppen und NRA und so zum Projekt 2025 zusammengeschlossen
haben und ein komplettes Playbook für Trumps nächste Präsidentschaft geschrieben haben.
Also im Prinzip fast sagen, wie sie die Machtergreifung durchführen wollen.
Und ein wichtiger Punkt ist, den Status für alle staatlich Beschäftigten zu ändern,
weil Trump sich darüber beklagt hatte, dass laufend ihm irgendwelche Leute gesagt
haben, das geht nicht, das ist ungesetzlich, das tue ich nicht, das ist verboten.
Und er meinte aber,
alle Bundesangestellten sollten für ihn arbeiten und eben im Prinzip die Liste derer,
die einfach aus politischen Gründen entlassen werden können,
im Prinzip endlos ist.
Also dass wenn, was weiß ich, jetzt der Wetterdienst irgendwie eine Hurricane-Vorhersage
macht und Trump gefällt das nicht so,
wie es tatsächlich während der Präsidentschaft war und er malt halt dann noch ein Stück Region dazu,
die auch gefährdet ist aus seiner Sicht, Dann würde das in Zukunft so aussehen,
dass dann einfach auch die Wettervorhersage nach Trumps Wünschen und Gelüsten arbeitet.
Das würde natürlich auch zu einem massiven...
Rückgang oder Leute würden in Scharen den öffentlichen Dienst verlassen.
Und ich habe mit einer Reihe von Leuten gesprochen, die in Amerika davon betroffen sind.
Und die machen sich alle deutlich Sorgen.
Und ganz viele haben gesagt, also dann bin ich raus.
Weil es ist auch so, in den USA viele Dienste,
also im Staatsdienst sowohl Militär, aber auch im Auswärtigen Amt und so,
da schließt du 20 Jahresverträge.
Beziehungsweise ist es so, du verschließt einen unbegrenzten Vertrag,
aber nach 20 Jahren kannst du ausscheiden mit voller Pensionsberechtigung.
Du kriegst mehr Pension, wenn du natürlich dann bis ins Rentenalter arbeitest,
aber wenn du 20 Jahre voll hast im öffentlichen Dienst,
dann hast du deine Pension sicher und kannst was anderes machen.
Und ja, das werden halt dann tonnenweise Leute tun und das wird halt einen ziemlichen
Niedergang der USA bedeuten und eigentlich erinnert das Ganze, was dort geplant ist,
an die Machtergreifung.
Man kann das sicher nicht eins zu eins, aber diesmal kann man nicht davon ausgehen.
Dass die Trump-Präsidentschaft uneffektiv sein wird.
Und er hat ja auch schon angekündigt, dann die Unterstützung für die Ukraine
einzustellen und den Krieg in fünf Minuten zu beenden.
Wenn er gewinnt. Wenn er gewinnt, genau.
Das halte ich nach wie vor für die unwahrscheinlichere Option.
Aber das haben wir natürlich auch bei der ersten Wahl schon gedacht.
Aber es ist vollkommen außer Frage, dass das der totale Super-GAU wäre.
Und das muss natürlich verhindert werden.
Die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass er gewinnt, ich folge das seit einer Weile,
wenn wir sagen, die Eintrittswahrscheinlichkeit schwankt zwischen 20 und 80
Prozent in den letzten drei Monaten.
Weil eine Verschiebung von nur wenigen Prozentpunkten macht halt einen großen
Unterschied bei der Eintrittswahrscheinlichkeit aus.
Also wenn wir sagen, 5 Prozent weniger Unterstützung heißt dann gleich 80 Prozent
weniger Eintrittswahrscheinlichkeit oder so.
Ja aber ja,
und es sind halt nur Vorhersagen und es kann noch viel passieren bis dahin und
mit ein bisschen Pech, also leider ist die Situation nicht so,
dass man es komplett ausschließen kann dass er gewinnt oder irgendeine andere
Nummer polt aber ich hoffe es,
ich hoffe inständig dass uns das erspart bleibt, weil,
Das wäre dann in der Tat nicht gut.
Ich hatte eigentlich auch vor, dieses Krisenprogramm irgendwann dann auch mal
gegen was anderes auszutauschen.
Aber selbst wenn Trump jetzt geschlagen wird, ist die Frage,
ich meine die Konservativen haben jetzt Blut geleckt und die Methoden und die
Playbooks und so ist alles da, ist nicht ausgeschlossen, dass sie dann irgendjemand
anderen aufbauen und dass sich das nur um fünf Jahre,
wir die Katastrophe nur fünf Jahre in die Zukunft verschieben.
Jetzt ist aber Schluss mit Doomsday, Pavel, weil ich meine, wenn sie jetzt nochmal
verlieren, dann haben sie auch in den letzten acht Jahren nichts anderes gelernt, als zu verlieren.
Und ob das jetzt wirklich so das Playbook für die Zukunft ist,
da habe ich so ein bisschen meine Zweifel.
Also ich glaube da ehrlich gesagt noch an die Resilienz der USA und wir werden
auch wie bei der letzten Wahl wieder eine hohe Motivation sehen von Leuten, die sagen,
das geht mal gar nicht, Zumal ja die wirklich motivierenden Themen wie zum Beispiel
eben der Kampf gegen Abtreibungspolitik der Republikaner durchaus ein hohes
Mobilisierungspotenzial hat.
Mal komplett abgesehen von dem internationalen Geschehen, was die Amerikaner
ja in der Regel sowieso nicht interessiert.
Okay, jetzt dann vielleicht, um doch nochmal auch mit was Positivem zu ändern, was ich erwarten würde,
falls Trump gewinnt, weil er ist ein Populist und er ist der Typ,
was interessiert mich, mein Geschwätz von gestern.
Und dass er mitnichten die Unterstützung für die Ukraine streichen wird.
Irgendein Stunt wird da versuchen, aber er wird nicht die Unterstützung für
die Ukraine komplett beenden, weil ein guter Indikator ist, seit Beginn des Krieges.
In sämtlichen Pols unterstützen 60 Prozent der Amerikaner die Ukraine.
Das hat sich nur um ein oder zwei Prozentpunkte verschoben im Laufe der Zeit.
Und nur zwischen 20 bis 30 Prozent in der Größenordnung unterstützen nicht die Ukraine.
Aber die Ukraine ist auch nicht so ein großes Thema in der USA.
Die ist bei uns ein viel größeres Thema und in der Ukraine natürlich noch größeres
Thema als jetzt innenpolitisch.
Obwohl es da eine ganze Menge Drama drum gab, ist die Bevölkerung geht nur zu
einem geringen Teil dort mit.
Die scheinen sich auf andere Themen mehr zu fokussieren.
Es scheint wohl eher ein C-Thema zu sein. Klar.
Du kannst keine Präsidentschaftswahl mit internationalen Themen gewinnen,
es sei denn, die USA ist gerade im Krieg.
Mit anderen Worten, die Gefahr ist da, geschildert, Aber es wird,
wie immer, anders kommen, als man denkt.
Und wie gesagt, die Tatsache, dass eben die Unterstützung in der amerikanischen
Bevölkerung, die haben einfach instinktiv Wissen,
die Russen, die führen halt nichts Gutes im Schilde.
Das ist einfach so eine Grundüberzeugung der Amerikaner.
Und da ändert sich auch nicht viel dran.
In den letzten drei Jahren. Und insofern könnte man fast sagen,
ja, Trump kann zwar viel Unheil anrichten potenziell, aber selbst wenn das passiert,
wird es nicht so schlimm.
Und wahrscheinlich im Moment sieht es so aus, dass es eben nicht passieren wird.
Und ich finde es aber, für mich ist unbegreiflich, wie es überhaupt so knapp sein kann.
Damit tue ich mich wirklich schwer, das nachzuvollziehen.
Aber das, gut, ein Grund dafür liegt aber insgesamt, dass die amerikanische
Politik, auch die der Demokraten, ziemlicher Fuck-up ist.
So, ja, für einfach viele Leute so, ja, insbesondere der Anstieg der Mieten.
So, Mietenanstieg ist halt so eines der größten Themen dort,
weil Wohnen in den USA zunehmend unbezahlbar wird.
Und das ist halt unter anderem ein großes Thema.
Und das haben eben auch die Demokraten mit zu verantworten.
Mit Finanzliberalisierung und anderen Dingen. Aber ja, ich glaube,
wir können es dann hier langsam damit beenden lassen, oder? Deutlich.
Wir machen jetzt nicht nochmal das ganze USA-Wahlen-Thema auf, weil das ist für zu weit.
Gut, also Leute, not all is lost.
Es geht leider weiter im Krieg, aber ich bin nach wie vor positiv,
dass dieser Konflikt am Ende von der Ukraine und vom Westen gewonnen wird.
Allein schon, weil der Westen langsam begreift, dass er ihn nicht verlieren kann und darf.
Und das kann noch viel zu lange dauern, aber es ist am Ende unvermeidbar.
Und mit diesen Worten würde ich euch jetzt gerne verabschieden.
Ja, und die ersten drei Jahre von den von uns prognostizierten Zehn sind Oma.
Du hast Zehn prognostiziert, ich nicht. Okay, okay.
Vielen Dank fürs Zuhören, Leute. Bis bald. Macht's gut.
Ciao.